[Music]
hey everybody what's going on Friday
night oh my God what the [__] just
happened t look like the table shook or
something like that oh okay I don't know
what that was I didn't touch it I swear
it couldn't have it couldn't have shaken
there's nothing okay oh it's probably
just the camera moved oh maybe
it's ghostly [__] you're doing ghostly
[__] no I ain't doing ghostly [__] there
you go you you have been doing some
ghostly [__] yes ghostly [__] has
happened yet recently yeah we can talk
about it later I guess people are still
showing up Sebastian said would it would
be good if Tom and Jenny had viewers
call in about their paranormal
experiences yeah wonder how we could set
that up you have to have it so
um I think there's a way to do it um
yeah there is because they do it they do
those big Mass I know things that might
make a good that actually might make a
good show to have some regulars come in
every now and then on the U on Sid
tracks yeah but I don't know how to do
it you don't know how to do it either do
you well I mean joint I'd figure it out
but cuz like just like I do everything
else I got to figure everything else out
yeah I could barely see any of this [__]
I could look on well I'd probably just
like look on YouTube or something how
they see how other people do it
figure it out but yeah that's how I've
nobody taught me how to do any of this
[__] I just kind of like cobbled it
together from looking up other people
doing the [__] on the internet they're
still piling in it is Saturday no it's
not it's Friday
Friday I me uh you know what I'm talking
about I'm talking about in some parts of
the world it's Saturday it's the weekend
yeah where I me it's the weekend and
much like lover boy we're all working
for the weekend like we need some
[__] headbands yeah we worked off and
on all day today Jen's been [__]
slamming all day and I have yeah and
then uh so we just fired up the first
drink and uh we're sitting here yeah I'm
kind of worn out so I'm kind of glad to
like be hanging out with you guys yeah
drinking we're not going out tonight no
well we got to go well they're doing a
special momento Mory on Wednesday night
the night before Thanksgiving so so we
got to save some money so we had to save
up for that I guess so we'll kind to try
to stay in this weekend cuz they I'm
kind of tired though I don't think I
could handle yeah I'm kind of tired too
be honest I might be able to go we I
mean we've been getting up kind of early
yeah you've been waking my ass up at
like 7 o' yeah I want some I know
yeah that's what it's like 7 o'clock and
he's just like gling on like grabbing
the I'm like
what got her on her side why are you
waking me up got grab I'm like cradle
and boot boobs and stuff I wake up
boobs he does it's not even an
exaggeration not exaggeration at all
it's not and I'm just and I'm all cranky
cuz I'm like why you waking me up yeah
I'm I'm ready to go like get
up pull like stop pulling on me yeah
trying to pull her over and Sh roll over
she's
fighting pull [__] pillows and
[__] she's used to it though
well yeah you do it pretty much every
day to the uh
yeah oh man hey everybody's here [__]
Zach's here murder Hornet just showed up
hey everybody go here Danny Rowling's
here Sebastian's here JX Jason is here y
Hugo's here did you say that already
yeah I wasn't listening is uh Miss Lim
Lee from Korea is she in here not yet I
don't think so well sometimes I think
she just hides in there oh okay and then
you'll got to hide it's okay she's I
think she hides sometimes cuz then
she'll just we're all mad here we'll
just mention something about Korea Bo
and then she says something oh yeah yeah
yeah well not everybody can like is
going to comment on everything because I
don't do that I don't watch a lot of
live streams to be honest with you yeah
I like them I watch them I mean mostly
about entertainment though I think the
only live stream I watch with any
regularity is when Dan used to do the
ones on Saturday night yeah but
sometimes I didn't I mean usually we
were out Saturday so I didn't watch them
live I watched them like the next day
he's driving around Baltimore try to get
these screwdrivers working yeah
really yeah Zach says also uh for the
Callin thing you guys could always start
a Discord server yeah I know I know
there's like so many things there
there's so many things that I could do
and it's just kind of like I don't know
I always feel like I have like 20
projects going at once and I'm just like
really disorganized she's super busy
right now so it's just kind of like like
yeah I could do that but let me just put
that on my million item list she's
looking for looking looking for jobs
graphic design jobs doing graphic design
work like freelance stuff yeah going on
interviews um she's taking all these
tests to do all these
online uh gigs that they have have
something to do with the AI yeah like
transcription type stuff yeah um getting
shows ready yeah uh [__]
everything um make porn made a custom
yeah made some had somebody buy a custom
vid yeah it it's her best work so far it
[__] looks good I did it today well
actually we shot we shot it the first
time on Wednesday but it didn't really
come out that good like the lighting was
kind of [__] yeah and so was the audio
we tried to well Tom had the idea it's
like oh we could shoot it in the bedroom
but and we had like natural light and
stuff like that which on paper sounded
kind of good but then like when we
watched it back I was like me yeah it
was kind of like the Shadows were kind
of harsh and yeah and it was pi ating on
the other side with if your back lit
yeah it was too dark really yeah and I
had I had resolution set too low and the
audio wasn't really that the audio
wasn't that good because so I just so I
just redid it like today like I made it
in here the audio on my action cams I
got two of them is not the microphones
are not very good I think there's an
external mic um upgrade for that yeah to
get I have one on my other C like camera
over there and external mic but I don't
think it works okay I'm going to look
more into external mic upgrade for that
see what the deal is cuz I got I got a
uh an
LED light for it it's got its own
rechargeable battery it's cool it's like
a little bitty camera like they're
little action cams we got them so we
could do like outdoor shots so like you
could take them with you yeah I can put
them on on my helmet camor like that
kind of stuff cuz they're really small
yeah they make an uh an external mic
that you can put inside your helmet and
um so it's it's got noise reduction
involved in some of that stuff but I
think there's like like a shotgun type
mic that goes on there too for like
doing interviews and stuff what would be
great for porn yeah cuz I like they're
little and you can put them on the end
of a rods like selfie sticks so you can
get angles you know CU it's got image
stabilization on the thing it's it's a
[__] aaso Brave 7 which is like a
it's a GoPro knockoff it's a Chinese
GoPro knockoff it's okay not as good as
a GoPro but it's even got a it's even
got
a a um a small screen on the front of
the camera so when you flip it around
you can do selfie with the video camera
you can look into the video and get it
get an image little tiny screen the size
of a postage stamp really only issue I
have with it is that when you I mean
it's it's really good cuz it's tiny it's
like really really small small than a
pack of cigarettes yeah it's like so you
can just like put it in your pocket and
like take it anywhere which is awesome
but that's also kind of a detriment
because when you're filming stuff it's
like oh that looks awesome when you see
it this big but then you blow it up to
like you know TV size you're like ah
that kind of looks like ass okay I don't
have a whole lot of experience with them
I'm just trying to get the settings
correct and yeah I think the problem we
had before I don't think the resolution
settings were high enough it was on that
what is it 720 it needs to be on uh was
it 10 80 60 frames per per second is
really yeah 60 Fram I mean normally I do
30 frames per second yeah but you have
to have 60 frames per seconds in order
to achieve image stabilization yeah
that's that's why we were trying to do
it and we were also had two cameras we
had he was walking around with a camera
and then we had a stationary one like
from a different angle because the the
guy wanted like a specific thing thing
like he wasn't super specific I mean he
was kind of vague but he did kind of
want this one situation so I was like
okay well we need to like figure out
what angle we're going to do that from
yeah it's a real good solo scene she's
putting on a show and basically beating
it to a
[__] a [__] [__] an image of of
the dude's [__]
junk I got that on a big we he sent it
to us I got it on a big [__]
um tablet I put that in a picture frame
in set and then had the camera set up
and she basically goes to like a strip
of routine [__] off off the working
off the floor she's dressed up she looks
[__] great it was fun to do she's
never looked this good [__] her
training man she's [__] she looks
totally different she looks like an
adult film actress
yeah I'll take that as ACC yeah you do
well you saw it yeah you saw it I
thought it came out good you're right it
doesn't I would
say probably in terms of appeal I think
I think the guy's probably going to see
probably 50% greater than than what you
were when you started it was it's a big
change this change is so big that she
hasn't fully adapted to it yet her
body's still kind of catching up with
because there was a lot of fat loss and
and a lot of gained a lot of muscle and
a lot of um's weird [__] yeah what do
you call it not weird not weird but no a
lot more uh what do you call it
definition yeah in certain areas she's a
lot more I mean her waist is [__]
real small now we put her small corset
on the shoot fit in [__] 10 years
ago and it just slipped right on it was
and you could I could make it so small
that it didn't look good went back to
the bigger one yeah um because just
you could just scrunch her down to
nothing but I have some that are smaller
than that yeah from what I was really
really scar that's when you're really
small I've got some 18 inchers in there
yeah everything all has the thing is is
you built up some muscle too your your
shoulders and your back [__] look
really good you it you can't really
scrunch it down that far yet you just
got to wait yeah cuz of course it's too
tight I'm going to get some back fat
action happening yeah well what like top
muffin top on the top yeah cuz the
Skin's loose right it's going to take a
while because she's lost so much she
lost 35 pounds of fat in maybe a month
maybe a bit longer but not that much
longer though month and a half yeah
something like that like six weeks or
something yeah and you know she's on
stuff that'll
help collagen synthesis so the skin will
snap back I've seen her skin snap back
before she's got real good skin about
that but it it just takes time skin
wasn't designed to react that quickly
yeah but it's not like she's losing 200
pounds though
so yeah it's not a lot and really I
don't have that much more I like if I
lost another 15 20 that would be good
well and fat really you probably only
need you PR probably really only want to
lose like another 10 you think yeah but
then you want to put on about another 10
15 lounds of muscle well that would work
too in the lower body big quads big butt
it'll [__] look good yeah
yeah your calves are looking [__]
super good her ankles are getting like a
little bit bitty ankles he's been going
on sheing being like I'm going to buy
you some anklets let me get you some
anklets yeah cuz you know you know how
his thing is with this weird Shoe Fetish
it's not it's not weird I got shoe
fetishes and anklet
fetishes yeah it's weird cuz you're not
you're not into feet not that no no
you're not really into feet no not
really into feet just like shoes you
just like shoes on shoes and ankles and
stuff yeah well yeah I mean you pretty
much like everything but I like
everything it's just just it's just one
of the little things that like a little
side thing yeah he does like shoes
that's why that's why he buys me so many
it's not so bad that I just need the
shoe they got some dudes that's so bad
they don't even need the woman they just
want the shoes yeah they just got a
whole closet full of shoes and they can
just like Jerk it to the Sho Jer it to
the shoes that not that bad I got to
have the woman in there yeah but at some
shoes I put him on and he's just kind of
like [__] lose
it was like well I'm just going to lay
here cuz I can't walk in these but you
know yeah anything looks anything that
looks like it it it would hurt me like
you can't walk or or it's kind of
painful big spike heels a lot of big
huge platforms on them and real on your
balls in it yeah anything that look like
step on you and hurt you yeah I like
that I like that that's hysterical it's
just a thing yeah and if the back side
of the arch is a different color I like
that too they have black shoes with
[__] the inside Arch on the bottom of
the shoes red that looked good that
looks good too I like that sounds pretty
they're just a little bit more expensive
yeah
that sounds pretty yeah but you got to
walk in them see yeah that's the that's
the issue isn't
it take takes practice you used to be
able to do it I think on
streammate we we had a guy that tipped
us and wanted you to put my shoes on
yeah gave me1 just $10 but they don't
fit I said they don't never fit you goes
try them on I give you
10 they say it ain't going to work he
gave me to to cuz cuz he was like yeah
let's see if you can walk in those but
but he can't put him could get him on
yeah no cuz it's you you don't have like
huge feet but you have bigger feet than
me cuz I have I have little bitty feet
yeah well that there was that was
impossible to get it you know yeah there
was no way but she had the camera says
watch it ain't going to work he's
laughing just try just try man look at
this that was [__] funny he goes I'll
pay you just try couldn't get couldn't
get it in there that was hilarious
couldn't get it in and he gave it to him
I was
just do a lot of that [__] that that we
did on on stream it was G type stuff
yeah I mean kind of like a gag like
getting Jenny to sit on my face that was
a fun one and try to
suffocate I was [__] laughing I was
laughing well we had somebody we had a
different person like that wanted the
opposite yeah yeah too yeah so I also I
also might have been the same dude just
on a different day maybe with a
different
[Laughter]
name says on
a on a scale one to 10 how will we rate
the stream mate
experience so
far about a five yeah I was going to say
for like a five or a five it's like it's
boring it can get boring yeah that's the
only thing I think the issue um I don't
we haven't had problems really with
people being [__] or anything like
that um we've been asked to do some
weird [__] but nothing that weird or
painful or anything so that's not really
the issue but a lot of it it's just like
boring you're waiting cuz you're just
basically waiting around you know what I
mean it's just like you know like you're
in Amsterdam and like the girls are in
the windows of thing being like hey come
in here and like give me some money so
it's just it's kind of like that so a
lot of it is just kind of like sitting
around waiting being like hey come on
you know what I mean and it's just kind
of like you know and then you're sitting
there for like two hours and yeah you
you can sit there for two and a half
almost three hours not saying much of
anything and nobody really even walking
in and then all of a sudden some dude
comes in and you [__] pull down a 100
bucks right you never know you never
know
so but the thing is you get sick of just
waiting yeah because you can't really I
mean I have seen other people on there
just like on their phones or yeah
knitting or what have you but it's like
I don't know I have thought about doing
that though yeah the the the what what
would be the best gig is have Jen over
here working and I set the camera and
the lights up and she's sitting and it's
just watching her work and I can
actually get work done while I'm yeah
but she's working so I'm doing two
things she dress up like a sexy office
lady right with a [__] SE office lady
yeah with glasses and a [__] suit and
all kinds of [__] and um dudes would
come in and just bother her try to get
her to do something while she's working
that'd be a great and then I'll be all
pissy about it yeah yeah I gotta work
okay then you you go into a [__] into
a
show the dudes are only [__] in there
between five and 10 minutes anyway yeah
you rarely get somebody in there long
they're rarely in there for long time
we have had a few that were in there for
like 15 minutes but that way you're
working you're actually getting stuff
done that's so I'm actually get yeah
because I think that's kind of the issue
is just kind of like I'm sitting here
it's like I could be making $100 but
then I could be doing something else
that makes money over here that makes
money too and it's just like so I kind
of feel like I'm not really sure what I
should be doing you know we we have like
a wide spectrum of different gigs
running yeah I I have like robots are
selling merch for us invisibly out on
the internet shirts and [__] glasses
and [__] you know what I mean it just
but it's just a little bit here and
there she sells audio books robots you
know on [__] Amazon sell audio books
and books for audible yo we're an we're
an audible affiliate click the link down
in the thing we actually do the
commercial actually well I don't usually
do the commercials on sidetracks because
I would do it I would do it every
[__] show that you could every live
stream I would do it it is in the
description box though yeah the link um
you get a month free trial yeah
audible's good it's it's good it is yeah
it is if you like I said I wouldn't I
wouldn't affiliate with anybody that
didn't have that didn't have like good
[__] I'm I'm going to recommend this for
about audiable you can if you join up
with
audable um you can get like I think what
is it some coupons or something to get a
couple of your books at a reduced price
are free I think no you get a month free
you get a month free right you get well
30 days okay and then you get uh one
credit that you can spend on whatever
you want and you can keep that forever
if you're already Amazon Prime member
you get two credits that you can spend
and you get to keep that she's got a
[__] ton of audio books up there if you
like to listen to the show and fall
asleep while if you like amsr and listen
to us and fall asleep you know because
I've heard people use us to fall
soothing which was in a slightly higher
register back when I recorded those but
still what I would do is I would get
like I would get one of her audio books
maybe something like unseen hand and she
just sits there and [__] talks about
all these [__] Poltergeist about
ghosts and [__] yeah not really ghost
yeah that that was a pretty long one two
different things and if if you fall
asleep it's all right you go back over
there and you start where you fell
asleep and you restart I can't remember
how long it took me to do that book yeah
uh was it seven hours eight hours I
don't remember and there's a bunch of
True Crime on it's pretty long so um if
you like to listen to the show you know
before go to sleep you know or while
you're going to sleep if you want to
hear about murders yeah get get some her
audio book go to sleep listening about
murders I do that we make money on
either end you joining and then her
buying her her book first yeah yeah
sure like I said following that
affiliate Link Link in the description
box I always put it in there we have a
skillshare one in there too so you help
us out and we help you out you get
something in
return uh let me
see stil on balls people into goth sex
on stream mate um I I don't think we've
had anybody specifically like a lot of
people will
compliment if I have like a cool outfit
on or something oh goth couple yeah yeah
so people do like the look but you know
doesn't really have anything to do with
that what we're doing that's what I mean
like kind of like it's just regular sex
they do have a lot we just we just look
cooler doing it that's all they have a
lot of C girls in there working solo of
different types you know
um but uh somebody oh [__] Grand as
well if you get bored just start just
start screwing in there no he said yeah
the Colombians eat lunch watch TV talk
on the phone Etc and then start shagging
yeah well the Colombians are they're on
there like all day they're on there all
[__] day they don't make much they
don't make much money but that little
bit that they do make is a lot of money
in Colombia yeah all right so but we
couldn't live like that I mean that's
[__] crazy what they do um I mean I
don't think I don't understand how they
don't get [__] banned because they
they're they're Breaking All the Rules
yeah like I said technically you're not
really supposed to do anything quote
unquote below the belt in public you can
show titties you can like suck on a
dildo you can do that kind of stuff but
you can't like show dicks you can't show
your Co you can't show anything they're
doing all that yeah and it's just kind
of and we see people doing that all the
time I'm like how are they getting away
with this maybe nobody cares or nobody
reports it
or I heard that you know streamate
employees like would come in there like
every now and then like check and make
sure you were minding your p's and q's
but maybe they don't have enough people
to do that so maybe no one's monitoring
or they don't care about Colombia or
maybe maybe they don't make a lot of
money from Colombia but they make enough
not to want to lose it and if they make
them follow the rules that money will
dry up maybe it could be that it's not
just them because I've seen like
Americans and British people doing that
[__] too yeah but they would probably
come in there eventually and say hey
stop that I mean you can there's ways to
get around it like as long as you're not
like showing anything anything it's kind
of stupid to do that on stream mate
though if you're going to do anything in
public go to chatterba go to ChatterBait
yeah that that's the Roman Coliseum cuz
then you can just do whatever the [__]
and then you're just trying to get tips
you know what I mean and the thing there
is that you
got you might have 7,000 people watching
you only three or four PID right but out
of those three or four PID it might end
up work you might work out ahead yeah
and but there you're not you're just
doing a straight live SE show in public
yeah there's yeah there's no like
restrictions I think the only things I
don't think you can do like um uh you
can't do yeah or scat or you can't do
anything like that um but I think those
are the only restrict well in
beastiality and like that obviously but
um but other than that you can do pretty
much whatever like I said I've heard
some people like
ChatterBait
um and in some ways I can see that that
would actually be fun because you
wouldn't just like be sitting around
like blue balls all the time like um
waiting for somebody to come in and pay
to do something but um on the other hand
I I don't know if I would really like
the idea of just like being out there
doing whatever and then maybe not
getting any money maybe you'd get money
and maybe not but it would it might be
less boring my ex Ela and her husband
that I introduced her to do ChatterBait
or did it they did do it for a while ala
didn't like it so she didn't like the
comment section because everybody's yeah
they're real rude in the comment section
I can see that they're real you know
there's no quality control when it comes
to customers so then they're talking
[__] about you you know about what you
look like and [__] so yeah I can see how
that would really like and I don't even
I I'm like the kind of person that
doesn't generally give much of a [__]
about other people's opinions especially
when they're losers but yeah after a
while it's just like it's like Chinese
water torture it's just it'll get to you
after a while even if you
don't like you know even even like I
said if I think it's just like a bunch
of losers in their mom's basements or
whatever and it probably is but it does
wear on you after a while some people
just cover cover the [__] comments up
they don't even see anything you make
money or you don't that's probably what
I would do to be honest cuz like what
the [__] would I care what they have to
say I'm sure it's they got some other
I'm sure I'm sure they're not
contributing to the uh you know
discourse of Greater Humanity or
anything so they got they got some other
ones that you can live stream through a
mobile a mobile device yeah and I watch
[__] this one where it's these two
Central American girls that might have
been Columbia and they're just walking
around the park and then at random
[__] they they're in public at random
[__] jumping around the bushes and
doing something for like three or 4
seconds and then [__] walking away
like nothing you going down on each
other or [__] this and that you know
just anything those are fun yeah and
they're like trying to get away with it
they were making money well people like
those yeah I like those yeah cuz it's
like it's kind of like driving around
they can get caught a lot of people like
those driving around got she's got a
camera on her and she she's in her car
by herself and the [__] the phone's
on her and she's [__] she's flat
flashing and [__] flashing people in
traffic and making
money yeah there's got there's got to be
a dude in the passenger seat though
probably because that would be dangerous
you flash some dude he's gonna follow
you well yeah you know I mean they might
do that anyway like even you don't so
well the boyfriend are is a bouncer
anyway I would be scared to I would
never ever do anything like that by
myself ever no cuz that's
just another one is so dangerous Yep
they're also doing they had a goth chick
that would go through the
mall going to mall going to mall
bathroom do a quick scene then come out
[__] walk around the mall
flashing um people are walking around
but she just times it right so nobody
sees it but you think security might see
it they're looking through the cameras
but I guess she doesn't care yeah and
then um she'll go and uh go in a car do
stuff in the car and she's by herself
you could tell she's by
herself see I I would be scared to do
that then she goes into the restaurant
she puts the phone up on the restaurant
while she's eating and flashing the
camera putting the camera let doing
upskirts and stuff with the
camera we saw one one time a long time
ago it was like an amateur video where
it was a couple and she was blowing him
in it looked like a McDonald's right
yeah it was a McDonald's yeah yeah but
they were kind of like there and then
like there was other people like right
there so they kept like going like that
like making sure nobody was turning
around look
at I don't think that was I think that
was a Canadian McDonald's too I don't
think that was in the United States yeah
it might have been it's a biracial
couple cute hippie white chick probably
in her 20s big old [__] uh [__]
muscular black boyfriend probably late
20s and they were [__] doing some
wild [__] in the McDonald's they do [__]
at home too they got money whatever they
do they
got they're they're an educated couple
they're professionals some sort but um
this sh was wild what they were doing
and you can see in the
background the people that work at
McDonald's [__] sering food it was
night time yeah and behind them was the
was the parking lot there was a big
window so they should be able to see
everything her ass is hanging out over
the side he's [__] doing stuff to her
like only a few seconds at a time right
yeah yeah yeah that's funny they were
they were live streaming it yeah but
they recorded and we're selling it they
sold
it I do kind of like that kind of stuff
though it's high risk yeah high risk
adrenaline although it does it kind of
stresses me out watching it too because
I'm like what they it but the thing
about it is like if if it's not a live
stream if it's recorded I'm like well
obviously they didn't get caught because
they wouldn't have uploaded it otherwise
but you know what I mean
well the live stream is being recorded
you can then well I know that but I'm
just saying no I'm saying that I'm not
not watching it live yeah yeah yeah so
it's like so obviously they didn't get
caught or if they did they edited that
out in the version that they saw when
somebody said hey are you blowing that
dude over
there no that wasn't yeah he just
dropped something on his penis and I was
licking it
[Laughter]
off that's that's that's the excuse I
would come up with cuz my hands are
nonfunctional they just uh come up with
[__] wild ways of making money during
a live stream and then the back side of
it they sell the live stream yeah they
record it re-edit it and sell
it Zach says uh you ever thought of
doing a book on the history of horror
movies I have actually I have thought
about that and I was thinking about it
more like um lately because I've been
doing you know I've been working on that
video that I'm eventually going to put
up because I'm writing this
massive essay about it which like I said
is taking way longer cuz I'm going like
decade by decade and I'm not not trying
to cover every single thing but I don't
know I'm just like a completist so
what's up Oracle Oracle just got here
hey what's going on talking about porn
again like always but yeah I mean I I
don't know I do kind of like those uh
those public ones I always kind of
thought we should do some stuff like
that we can do that I don't want to get
arrested
but if we do if we do that we should
live stream it but you can't do that
from stream M actually no they were
streaming from they did do that I did
see some people streaming from a remote
location but the the it is not set up in
a way that service isn't set up in a way
that would be real lucrative there's
there's other ones um the I think I
think the one that runs off the the
service that xHamster uses seems to be
I'll go back and check that out we get
approved for it because we're on other
platforms but that particular it's a
token site though yeah but that service
seems to be better at that kind of stuff
and you got to have a good
phone a good service you know with yeah
I probably need a better phone you need
a better phone better service cuz my
phone's kind of old so you make money
during the recording right all right and
then re-edit it and then sell it on Mini
vids or sell it you can actually sell it
through that same on that same platform
you can sell it an edited version of it
oh my God bamby's in the litter box and
she's so loud anything you record you
sell on every platform that you can
yeah Oracle said I got my contract
renewed until March 2024 awesome not
nearly as amazing as porn I know but it
means I can keep paying for a Kitty food
so the mighty Ash has decided to keep
loving me a it's like I said was saying
before we have so many gigs running at
one time that's just one of them yeah
and lately she's been too busy she's got
contract work and [__] to do graphic
designs so really that's things like
stream mates fill her that's when we
don't have anything to do yeah when we
don't have anything to do we do that
yeah the last couple weeks I've had like
[__] to do like every day graphic design
stuff pay is a sure thing and it pays
more basically per day yeah so
far yeah it's you know it's intermittent
yeah but we don't have a huge following
like my like Amy she can pull down
$300 $100 basically uh $300 a day or a
night she works a day and a night six
hours of work she can pull out 300 on a
good night I he showed me her paycheck
just on a BL night was more like 240
yeah where she'd do three hours and then
3 hours 3 hours in the morning and 3
hours in the
evening yeah so that's not bad
yeah that's not bad for six hours it's
not
bad but like you said she she's got
30,000 followers yeah she's got like a
huge amount of followers and she does
like she does other porn too and she so
she's like kind of known yeah whereas
we're kind of not we're not known yeah
we're only known for doing this yeah
which is something yeah better than just
being total nobody's you well I think
most of the followers we have on Mini
vids come from here probably I I do kind
of feel like it wouldn't surprise me the
guy that hired you to do
the to do that video was actually a a
subscriber might have been might have
been we don't know exactly who he was
yeah I don't know he was in
England I thought I'm not I thought you
said it was he was
British I'm not sure you're not sure
okay no I'm not
sure Zach says I've become obsessed with
a new horror game lately Allan Wake 2
it's trippy as hell I've never heard of
that actually I need to get more into
horror games when I have time because I
do like them but
although I have to say I'm more into
board games than I am video games I know
that's old lady of me genx Jason said
Tom and Jenny do you guys make your own
screens for screen printing yes we do I
like to use one color though just white
white on a black shirt cuz we don't have
like the whole setup where you can do
like the multiple colors the separations
yeah there's a mechanical machine you
need so you can have all of it to get
everything lined up so it's consistent
like I know how to do it but I hate
doing that kind of [__] it's aain theend
I like to make kind of like a nightclub
style shirt it's just a black shirt with
a white image on it just shoot it once
we made some with red but to be honest
on a black shirt you generally do need
like a white layer underneath the color
otherwise it's not going to really show
up but I got it's funny that you asked
that because I got 12 shirts
in from
Amazon six ribbed wife beers six
um Regular T's
black I have to get small now I have to
wear small yeah cuz my body shapes
changed so much I used to be able to
wear medium I put a medium on I look
pregnant because the way they're
tailored are [__] big in the
middle and I'm not big as big in the
middle as I guess the average guy
anymore you know so it's just it Billows
at the
bottom so it's funny I got bigger I
weigh a lot I weigh [__] 87 pounds
and I'm wearing a small yeah
you know it doesn't doesn't the small
look a hell whole hell lot better lot
yeah cuz you got some shirts that were
mediums that were just they didn't look
bad they were just baggy they're real
baggy on me now yeah in the middle cuz I
got Vaper now but see I have the same
thing it's just kind of like that's why
I always have to buy shirts that are
like fitted yeah because that's the
thing when you have big boobs if you buy
something that'll fit over your boobs
then it's just going to like sag like
over the rest of and it's going to be
too big so you have to get something
that's like tight and stretchy yeah like
that's what it looks good that's what it
looks good see show look that see look
at them things look at them things look
they got an un there's a UND section go
ahead there's an UND section there's an
under Section an under Section an over
section a middle section two sides side
section you can stand behind her and see
the
boob yeah she raises her arms you see
the boobs [__] stick out from the rib
cage they're pretty yeah Tom likes the
side boob it's side side boobs from the
back back side boob
yeah yeah Tom's into that kind of [__]
you're into like I said you're into
everything you love the shoes and the
suit side boobs and yeah all kinds I'm
observant what I'm observant I observe
[__] and I have certain tastes you know
now the my tastes are broad yeah you
know what I mean uh I like things that
are kind of
unusual but the quality's got to be good
you got to be good quality got to be
good quality yeah let me go get some ice
here yeah I'm running out okay Oracle
said uh did you hear there's a streaming
TV series starring crussell and Son of
crussell what okay we might have to
start watching that what kind of what
kind of show is it and like what is it
on I never hear about anything hardly I
don't know why it's just I'm always like
busy doing [__] it's like every now and
then I hear about like horror movies and
stuff cuz duh you know because I'm into
that but other stuff I'm just kind of
like what okay I'm like
clueless Zach says Allan Wake is
basically Twin Peaks meets an actually
good Stephen King novel okay in game
form and it's fascinating oh okay that
actually sounds pretty good so I'm gonna
need to like look at look that up he uh
she says it's called the the crussell
show I'm listening Monarch Legacy of
monsters it's about Godzilla and other
sh we where's it that's why I said I
don't know what platform it's on I mean
we could look it up probably but you
know probably easier like because you
guys might
know holy [__] we just spent like the
last three or four evenings watching
[__] The
Unexplained on Hulu the one with William
Shatner I can't believe that dude is
[__] how how old is William Shatner
now he's in his 90s right he still looks
pretty good for being in his 90s but um
yeah they put up season four of that
show that unexplained I don't know how
new it is they had [__] 22 Episodes
22 Episodes of that [__] like how are
they still like coming up with stuff
like to be because you know I don't know
it's a I don't know that that just like
is really comforting and like amusing so
we just like we did we we watch them all
so we have to find something else to
watch now but we've been going through
those like the last few nights like
watching the [__] unexplained like
it's like Oh weird Wild West and like
weird monuments and [__] like that it's
I don't know it's super
fun oh Apple TV only well
[__] um I watched the first episode
tonight and enjoyed it thought y'all
might like it yeah we're going to have
to uh we're going to have to look into
that we don't have Apple TV
though man I we have so many streaming
services I just I don't know what to do
I don't know what to do I don't even
remember what all ones we have we got
Hulu we got Amazon Prime we got shudder
got
uh HBO Max that came with my phone play
and then you got all the free ones like
tub and Plex and all that kind of stuff
so they got said it's on Apple TV which
we don't have that I didn't uh
finish what I was talking about though
well don't look at me he went into the
bathroom yeah I know we were talking
about making a uh making shirts
oh it's funny that you mentioned this
cuz I got in those shirts actually it's
a a pack of six two packs of six I got
12 t-shirts for myself I want to come up
with some new designs to replace the
designs you guys didn't didn't really
bite on uh of course I make them for
myself first because I'll I'll make a
bunch of them and wear them as you know
you know cuz I like there's [__] that I
want that you can't buy yeah I want to
do two tank themed shirts one of them is
just going to say
tank and it'll have like a star on it
and it's going to be kind of like an M4
Sherman World War II M4 Sherman
themed
shirt and then the other one is going to
say Panzer and it's going to have the
Roman numeral five pan paner five our
Panzer V what it'll look like and I'm
going to get that [__] looking right and
so it's going to be kind of like World
War to tank shirts they're going to look
real [__] cool it's like something
you could actually wear to a club
although I have to tell you that every
time I see you in that Panzer shirt I'm
immediately going to go computer machine
yeah computer machine pan pan yeah or
the [__] pan from [__] remember
from [__] that [__] and one song
yeah yeah what was the name of that I
like that song though yeah yeah but the
thoughts got to be correct in the p in
the Panzer
one um I'm just going to look at all the
thoughts they have to look kind of like
1940s military but maybe with like a
retro futuristic with a futur I could do
something like that you could do
something like that yeah I'm I I really
enjoy researching like fonts and design
styles from different eras yeah cuz I
did that like in some of my board games
I did a board game that was all based
around um abs houses yeah from like the
turn of the century in Paris and so I
went and researched like all and like
look I looked at ads and posters like
from back in that time period and like
tried to match the font and the colors
and everything now that my snake piskin
shirt was a [__] huge hit sold a lot
of them and I I'll wear those at Circle
K and and and I have young guys like man
that's a badass shirt man where'd you
get that shirt said have made that shirt
like oh like teenage boys see the
[__] you know late 17 18 year old
boys at Circle K freaking out over that
shirt that is a cool shirt guess they
know who snake pisin is they're probably
playing [__] all cool people know
probably playing [__] Metal Gear
probably how they Metal Gear is probably
how they like but that's okay yeah um um
Iris says hello been watching you both
for a while now just made a channel any
tips for beginners okay yeah well first
of all and everyone has their own taste
in games whether it's board games or
video games yeah that's friend friend us
on Instagram and tell or Facebook or
whatever or Facebook and and send us a
link to the channel this we want to see
your channel yeah and then um Tom will
give you all kind of advice kind he has
a lot more time to like talk to [__]
working a lot
but so he's probably like the one to
contact yeah I don't know like
what I'm not really sure cuz when we
started we didn't really know what we
were doing we just started it kind of
for fun because somebody told us we were
funny and we should do a show yeah and
uh you know they're like hey you guys
like horror movies and weird [__] it's
like why don't you guys should do a show
you're hilarious and so we were kind of
like uh well I don't know but then like
we start we were like well okay maybe we
should and then we started doing it and
it was kind of fun and then we just kept
doing it now iris is is this the channel
you're talking that you're promoting the
one the
iris the Irish channel is that the one
you're talking about did you or is there
another channel did you get the last
name right I can't say that Haney yeah
yeah yeah Haney or Haney I'm or Hane h a
y I don't know if it's that Channel or
if it's another
Channel yeah it's um and I'm going to
say too that it takes a while
to build up I mean we've been doing this
[__] since what
2016 and we only just got to 14,000
subscribers yeah so it took us that long
takes a long time and we didn't we
didn't really know what we were doing so
we just kind of like let's try this for
a little while let's try that for a
little while it's not working then we
just like abandon or even feel like
doing it anymore and [__] like that so I
don't know I feel like we don't worry
about it says that I'd probably like um
Invincible on Amazon Prime I don't know
what that is it's a series probably well
yeah I don't know what it's about though
yeah well you should look it up yeah
yeah Oracle said they've got three EP
EPS uh up so far of Monarch though the
one with crossle and if you like Kaiju
stories yeah a try yeah I should
probably what what service is that
Apple TV Apple T we don't have that I
know we don't have that I don't even
know how much that is is that can you
get it like for an add-on for something
or I don't know I'll have to look into
that Zach says speaking of fonts I'm so
mad because they made a custom font for
the Quantum of Solus title sequence and
I love it but it's not publicly
available but you know what any any kind
of movie though um that some designer
will make a font based on that and we
usually call it because I've been able
to find pretty much every font well I
don't know if every font but most fonts
from like most movies if there W if they
if somebody made that and it wasn't like
an already existing font somebody will
make a font of it like later on it's
funny that Zach like Quantum of soles
because you know he told me he said man
watch the new Bond that [__] was it
the the fourth one that's good too it is
different than the other ones but uh
it's grown on
me people were [__] on um qu msales
I think qu mes is my favorite one I
still think it's my least favorite but
it's a lot better than I remembered the
first time that I saw it like I
appreciate it a lot more like the more
times that I saw it it had a real cool
paranormal
angle it had a uh uh the enemy base out
in the middle of the [__] out in the
middle of the [__] desert all the out
alchemical symbolism about oil water and
fire and water that burns I don't quite
know what they were trying to say but
that looks like Alchemy there was
something symbolic happening there and
bond has a a paranormal event in the
[__] in the taxi when the taxi driver
says my mother my dead mother came to me
in my dream and told me that they were
stealing the
water that was [__] wild for a James
Bond movie because that's what was
happening [__] Spectre was stealing
the water rights of that country I think
that was [__] um did they say what
country that was Chile it wasn't Chile
was it oh I don't even remember now I
think it might have been was it a real
country or was it a made up country I
think it was a real country I think I
thought it was a madeup country but it's
been a long time since I've seen oh as
far as tips for beginners I don't and
you don't have to do this cuz we didn't
but I'm just saying maybe to avoid like
some headaches down the road um and this
is really rich coming from me CU I
totally don't do this but I think it's
good to have like if you have a channel
like to have a focus you know what I
mean like our [__] is all over the place
you know what I mean um and that's just
kind of how we roll because we do things
for a little while and then we get bored
of doing them that way and then just
change it up but I feel like channels do
better that are kind of like focused on
one thing you know what I mean or like
just a a very
small thing you know what I mean because
then people are like oh that's that
channel that does that reason to go to
it whereas our channel is just kind of
like when I have to explain it to people
I'm just like um okay how much time have
you got you know what I mean it's
because we just like talk about whatever
oh no it was Bolivia Zach said it was
Bol okay yeah thought I thought it was a
made up country no it was Bolivia okay
yeah it's been a while since I've seen
it as you can as you can see I've seen
that one seven eight times and I've seen
all of them about that much and I I I
think I like [__] Quantum I used to
like um Skyfall the best I think skyall
is still my favorite over time I didn't
like skyall as much I I like well that's
what happen that's why you rewatch
things you get different perspective and
different context there was something
about something about Quantum Solis I
liked it like I said I liked it a lot
more the more times I saw it you know
that happens sometimes sometimes if I
saw a movie one time and I was just kind
of like N I wasn't really feeling it um
you know a couple years later I might
give it another whirl and I'm just like
oh wow that's you see a lot more in it
like the second time maybe on uh Aon
bite Gnostic radio they had a guy was
called he did a show it was a guest that
came on did a show with him it was
called
um um theh what was it the I think it's
was called the nosis the nosis
of7 oh I remember that didn't we listen
to that yeah I think it's what it was
like together or something like that
no the Gnostic James Bond I think is
what it was called
called and this guy he was
a he knew a lot about the world's
religions and Rel religious gnosticism
and symbolism Alchemy and all kinds of
stuff and he was a James Bond fan and he
noticed that in most of the James Bond
movies there was there was an occult
symbolism happening in most of
them over the years but he said they all
kind of tied back with the way Ian
Fleming was that Ian Fleming was into
the occult
and James Bond in the movie James
Bond's
um religion is never given but evidently
in the books it's hinted or it's or
expressly says that he's a Manan which
is a dead
religion and if you kind of look at
manism manism is basically Jedi the Jedi
that's what it was they could be any
religion but they believed in a higher
God
and kind of like Paranormal abilities
they're talking about the Jedi and the
manin were it was like a synthesis of
Western religions and Buddhism and
that's what you have in Star Wars really
but evidently that's what James Bond's
religion was I've been wanting to do a
show about that actually about uh manism
yeah we need to do one I it's in my list
I put it in the poll a couple times but
it never wins most people are probably
like what the [__] is that they were
around for a long long time people don't
know about them they got Stamped Out of
existence by other religions over time
jerks yeah what was weird is that they
were uh kind of open open to other
religions like you could be say a Muslim
or a Christian and become a manikan it
was like an overlaying philosophy that
could go over it okay so it's like a
cooler religion it's not one of those
you can only have this religion you
can't you have toce my understanding is
they were kind of a synthesis of them
all and that uh kind of like kind of
like kind of like the
Masons but maybe less politicals
probably more spiritual I don't think a
lot survives from
them but uh it
was from what we know it was like half
Buddhism it was an East Meets West
religion what it was which sounds pretty
chill yeah yeah Oracle said the pope
declared the bakans to be Heretics in
the Middle Ages if I remember correctly
yeah he was he was always doing that
well they didn't want to they wouldn't
put themselves in a box yeah they were
openminded which we we like that I like
that they were seeking the truth and it
had a lot of elements of philosophy if
you got to have a religion then at least
have like a chill [__] religion you
know well we don't know if they were
chill no I know they had an organization
they had money I'm just being glib right
they might have been ruthless Killers if
you got in their way you don't know um
they probably were yeah they're going to
disappoint me but they were kind like
everything else does but evidently
evidently the Jedi were kind of like uh
based on manism basically I don't know
if it was directly or indirectly it's an
East a synthesis of east and
west Oracle also said that she found our
show uh our Logan's Run review and like
she liked our style a lot of people say
a lot of a lot of people say that that
was like a hugely popular review at the
time ridiculous and I don't know why I
guess at the time that we posted it
which was years ago now that was one of
the first ones we did I think yeah like
back in 2016 or 2017 there weren't many
Logan run reviews so it seemed like a
lot of people like saw that one I I
think we might have the best or biggest
Logan's Run review on YouTube we might
actually I think we do I mean there
might be more of them now and I got we
got the seal of approval from Hardcore
Logan's runs fans of that movie because
a lot of people [__] on that movie I
love Logan's Run yeah Logan's it's
nothing the series was good too it's
nothing like the book the book no it's
not it's not but that movie I thought
that movie was very cool and it would
have lasted longer had Star Wars not
come Star Wars came and it blew it out
of the water well and I mean Logan's Run
has its own thing going on so thank you
very much brycey always appreciated yeah
been around since 2016 that's amazing I
didn't know that would you ever do an
anniversary episode oh my God maybe we
should how long is it [__] I can't
believe that either yeah yeah we just
started um it was summertime I think we
were at a horror
convention and one of the other authors
that was there uh AR Armand Ros
rosamilia right
yeah and he had the table like next turn
we got to talking to him at this
convention he's like you know I have
like a podcast Network and it's like you
guys are kind of funny like cuz you know
we talk like this all the time and our
podcast was bigger than our [__]
YouTube show actually it was
on their Network we had like a lot of
download we had like 60,000 downloads
when we first started out but um so yeah
so he's just like oh you guys should
think about starting one because you
know I like your interaction is really
funny and it's like you know a lot about
horror and you know a lot about this
weird like True Crime and [__] and you
know people would watch that or people
would listen to that because we didn't
actually have a video component until
much later but um we're like ah yeah
maybe maybe we'll get around to doing
that and then we started doing that and
it was fun I think at first we only just
did one or two shows a week I think we
did like a main show which was usually
paranormal or true crime and then we did
a movie review and I think that's all we
did but then like as the years went on
we just started adding [__] we added
some [__] and we kind of abandoned it
because we just got sick of doing it or
ran out of material or whatever but it's
changed a lot and we just still do it
because it's fun you know what I mean
we're not like really worried about
it um let's see Zach said I found yall's
show back in 2018 right around when they
caught
D'Angelo yeah I think it was about a
week after you did your show about him
yeah that's right it's like we did a
show about the original nightstalker
before he was caught and then it was a
while before he was caught though I
don't remember when he did that show but
it was quite a while before he was
caught and then when they did catch him
I was like holy [__] I never thought
they'd catch that [__] and so we
were like oh my God we need to do a show
about that like now that they [__]
caught him
but yeah I I feel like the most of the
time like most of the people that say oh
I found your show like it was almost
always like the Logan's Run
review I just feel like that's the main
that's the Gateway the gateway drug is
the Logan's one run review yeah that one
in the uh uh and the rain War oh that
too I think it's our biggest show is is
and the rain I think it still is even to
this day well we've done a second one
where we talked about some of their
other cases too but I think the first
one and that was the one that we had
like got the most hate mail on yeah see
the thing is is that by a large
margin the for the amount of time we've
been around you'd think we'd have more
subscribers but if you look at other
shows that are like ours they have a
similar amount of subscribers in this
amount yeah I'm not really I mean and
the thing is I watch a lot of horror
content like people that have fewer
subscribers than we have yeah now here's
the here's the reason why I've heard
about
it they
have they have rigged the
algorithms to keep people from getting
too big too
quickly people who do get big quickly
either have some kind of corporate
backing and they have a lot of fake
followers or
they they got big out of just sheer
quality and
quantity and and they would have gotten
even bigger if those algorithms were not
in place so in other words they've been
hobbled and they're still huge
they have people like that yeah um
Midnight's I think it's called
Midnight's Edge who it's a real
good channel that talks about movies and
entertainment and it's about eight guys
from all over the world I think the guy
that actually runs it I think it's from
Sweden I think but Midnight's Edge got
huge in despite of what they did tried
they tried what they did to that channel
they tried to stop that from getting big
because it was critical about certain
things they didn't like they didn't like
certain things about Hollywood they
didn't like the writing and [__] they
were all right and and their predictions
all came true with what was going to
happen to Hollywood and Disney and all
that [__] they and right now [__]
Disney Disney's undergoing a hostile
takeover because it's been R just driven
into the [__]
ground and it's got to go back to family
entertainment and
uh it'll get better but it's going to
take a long time
there's going to be massive layoffs lots
of firings and a lot of people walking
off but they'll rebuild the guy that's
the guy that's doing the Hostile
takeover has a history of turning
companies around and he just does it by
going for the money you know he knows he
targets what the general public wants
and goes that way so you're going to see
more classic writing probably out of
Disney familyfriendly [__]
kid
oriented which that's what sells that's
what Disney's Market is that's what its
job is it's not to do this [__] crazy
[__] terrible reboots liveaction reboots
although I must say that the liveaction
reboot of Aladdin was good I didn't mind
it actually yeah I thought it was good
but that was one of the better ones they
got worse after that uh they said Little
Mermaid actually the quality was really
good and she did yeah I heard that was
pretty good that that girl we saw the
Dumbo one which was all right but not
all right yeah now the the reason why
Little Mermaid failed a lot of people
were saying well it's because she's the
wrong color I no that's not why it
failed it failed because Disney had
already lost the Goodwill of just
general uh [__] families with little
kids they're afraid to take their
[__] kids to see it you know they
don't know what Disney's GNA put out
because it puts out some [__] crazy
[__]
um and you can't predict what they're
going to say or do and you got a lot of
parents that are sensitive about what
their kids hear I mean this shit's got
to be
G-rated it's got to go back to the way
it was the 2000s you know 2010s which
and then it'll start making money again
Buzz Lightyear type
[__] Zach says what if you wrote like a
comedy horror story about fraud psychics
interestingly um I'm actually been
working on I had an idea to do like a
board game that was kind of based around
old school like spiritualism and
psychics and stuff like mediums cuz I
love that the aesthetic around that era
like all the old seances and stuff like
with all the old mediums like inside the
boxes with the ectoplasm coming out
their fingers and stuff I love that kind
of [__] so I'm I have like an idea for a
board game that's going to be like that
based around that which is going to have
like a backstory to it and stuff Tammy
says you guys have a very loyal fan base
we do I mean guys are here like every
[__] time we stream which is amazing
Oracle also says well we know awesome
when we see it oh that's nice yeah and
Bryce said something about girl how did
he find us well hang on I'm I'm I'm
working my way down uh Danny Rowling
says Ed Warren had an underage
girlfriend living with him and Lorraine
Al alleges that recently came
allegations really came out out about
the couple I think we mentioned that
yeah they've known didn't we mention
that like on the last show cuz we did a
second show about the Warrens like with
more of their cases but yeah they did
have allegedly I mean they're both dead
I guess but um they can't defend
themselves but I'm pretty sure they did
have was she underage I don't I I think
she was at at the beginning yeah that
was living with them yeah
which it was his girlfriend evidently
yeah okay but you know just Lorraine
knew evidently according
allegedly yeah like I said their dad
they can't defend themselves and and
they're charlatans allegedly but um you
know and uh just because that happens
you don't
know what the actual Arrangement was you
know that might have been a threesome
you don't know well that's what I was
picturing honestly well I'm not
picturing it cuz gross but you know what
I mean well they were all younger when
that happened that's yeah it it wasn't
like when they were super was when they
were real which like I said if it was
all consenting but if the girl was
underage obviously that's a whole
different different thing but if she may
have been underage when she moved in
there yeah which that's problematic um
if she
if she had been older then I wouldn't
have had may not have been maybe she
wasn't underage when when it went down
maybe it wasn't underage another thing
is is that people think underage is
under 18 no go back and look at your
state laws underage a lot of times means
under 16 or under 15 because that's the
age of consent
laws 18 is when the girl's legal to make
porn a dude could go to the Army at 18
be drafted be killed at 18 a girl
supposedly can make the decision to do
porn and dance actually in Canada if I
remember correctly a girl could dance
nude at 16 so a lot of the strippers
were 16 year
olds but the world was very different
when I was growing up uh you grew up a
lot faster they their maturity level
was better than today I would think in
some ways if I'd go that far no it was
real short attention spans and now and
they're not quite as sharp I mean I
remember 16-year-olds back then they
were not
mature yeah but probably better than
today they're INF infantilized today you
got to look at it this
way Japan and Germany was burned to the
ground millions of people killed by
18yearold [__] 18-year- old [__]
um B7 Pilots when you see those B17
bombers the pilots were 18 and 19 years
old flying them [__] things that's
[__] insane you'd never see that
today but that's the way the 40s
were you were a [__] adult at 18 you
were out [__] dropping fire on
[__] little children and [__] at that
age flying huge
bombers with no
computers man and that generation though
they call him the greatest Generation
that generation drank itself into an
early grave though too I mean you can't
really all the [__] [__] they did
yeah I'd be messed up too yeah
but uh they expected more out of people
back then and uh the girls were married
at 16 a lot of them 1617 they're married
and had
kids Bryce says I first came across you
guys with the Mr cruel episode oh yeah I
remember that one I couldn't remember
the name for ages until a goth friend
suggested your
podcast yeah Mr Cru Mr crru I forgot
about what was that about that was that
serial that was in um Australia now some
people thought that the original
nightstalker and Mr Cru were the same
guy because he had the balaclava thing
going on to you and like all that kind
of stuff but I don't know maybe we
should do a revisit on that I don't know
if there's been any like updates on the
Mr cruel case yeah in the but the Ed
Warren thing I think that girl was 15 or
16 which like I said problematic you'd
have to check the state laws at the time
whether or not that was considered to be
legal it's still creepy though like
considering how old they were yeah they
were in their 20s and 30s yeah so it's
still still creepy sorry yeah even if it
was legal the 70s though I think that
was the 70s or the 60s things were just
they their their consciousnesses were
different they they they had they lived
fast and died
young Danny ring said the Summer Wind
episode brought me here yeah yeah
Summerwind that was a good episode
that's one of my favorite that that's we
might have done a couple episodes about
that feel like I've seen that episode so
many times now it's still my favorite
haunting episode we watch that all the
time that one and the one with the
sneers and I don't have that on DVD it's
not available cuz that was with the
pilot the two pilot episodes was one of
the pilots wasn't it
yeah theer case and that was one of the
funeral home yeah and oh Mr Gordy and
Paranormal Witness did the sneers too
yeah but the haunting sneer case is a
lot better than [__] paranormal
Paranormal Witness one yeah yeah it
sounded a lot more compelling and you go
back to the source material and find out
what they really said it's not as good
good well they're always going to sex it
up for the show because obviously they
want people to watch it yeah yeah all
kind of other stuff happened that they
didn't like mention they didn't mention
right which you think they would because
that was like it's all salacious that's
going to get people to watch it but they
didn't I guess they were afraid people
would complain I don't think the SGA
case actually
happened I thought it sounds a little
farfetched I thought it did back in the
day when I first heard it after going
through the [__] m poter guys [__]
thing that we went through I thought
that maybe that was a possibility they
seemed compelling the the the
mom but what she's describing uh and
what other people describe it it's it if
it did happen it's highly
embellished yeah that's the thing I
can't I don't know it's hard for me to
put myself into the mindset
of some of the people and I'm not
mentioning any names but some of the
people that are on some of the haunting
episodes or the Paranormal Witness
episodes they come up with like some
real outlandish [__] because like I'm
not a real fantasy prone individual and
I'm not saying that these people are
lying or just like pulling stuff out of
their ass but I think that they might be
maybe some like minor weird [__]
happened and they just kind of blew it
out of proportion Danny says that
they're available as a two set on on uh
double feature of in uh Haunting in
Connecticut and Haunting in Georgia for
like $5 $5 for two and that's a that's
eBay yeah okay yeah because he said he
owns one okay yeah I'll have to get one
Zach said there was a Mr cruel update a
woman on Reddit suspected her stepdad or
stepbrother was Mr cruel cuz they both
[__] up dudes that abused her a lot
now okay I'm going to have to like look
that up CU that's been a while since
I've looked up that case I remember
writing about um Carmen Chan it was one
of the um alleged victims of Mr GRL like
in my book but I haven't really looked
at any updates since
then yeah both of them were full length
movies they were really good like both
of those were really good they were
really fun I don't know there's just
something like really comforting about
those haunting episodes I don't know
what it is like some of them aren't
particularly scary and some of them are
just like yeah I don't believe you
people come on you're just making it up
but it's just I don't I don't even care
I don't care if they're making it up
just tell me a good story you know it's
like I don't have to believe it I don't
believe most of them or like I said kind
of feel like
it's maybe they did see some weird [__]
but it was they just like embellished it
for the show and I do kind of feel like
too that sometimes it's not their fault
because I do kind of feel like the show
producers and sometimes it's kind of
obvious that they do this will edit
stuff in a particular way to make it
look more dramatic or make it sound more
dramatic and sometimes
too I don't know they they put stuff
into the reenactments that nobody
described so I I kind of Wonder because
I know that they come to your house or
what whatever they do they come to your
place and they you know record like
hours of interviews with you so there's
obviously a lot more of the interviews
than you see in the episode because they
just show you little bits of it so they
could be describing all of this stuff
and they're like okay we're going to try
and get it but obviously they're going
to make it look like a lot scarier the
thing that always pisses me off the most
is when they'll have a shot of somebody
you know washing the dishes or whatever
like in the
and then like a ghost will like walk
behind them but it's like they didn't
see that their back was turned you know
what I mean that was for us that was for
the benefit of the audience and I'm
always just kind of like I don't know
that just always feels like a cheat to
me cuz I'm like they didn't say they saw
that you know maybe that's how they're
visually trying to represent hey I was
washing the dishes and I thought I felt
somebody behind me you know that could
okay that's fair but I was like
otherwise you're just putting scary [__]
in there for the sake of the audience
and that's you know that that's not what
the people said they saw that's
all yeah Bryce said Australian police
now have a sketch of a suspect for Mr
Cru they think he was someone oh thanks
who worked on power lines and stuff okay
so there has been some movement on that
since I last heard about I don't
remember that
case I'm going to have to like look that
up it was kind of well the thing about
it like I said the reason that people
thought before they caught
D'Angelo um the reason that people
thought the Mr cruel case and the
original Night Stalker were related even
though Mr crru is obviously in Australia
was um because the Emos were very
similar so it was a similar kind of
thing to what original nightstar or what
D'Angelo was doing allegedly he hasn't
been convicted yet right D'Angelo no I
don't think so [__] I still need I still
need to read that book about him now
Dany those two episodes you said each
one's movie length long they're on the
same Blu-ray or DVD
just wanted to know yeah it's a double
feature a double feature yeah yeah look
it up
yeah cuz those are good those are like
yeah I've only seen them like once or
twice yeah me too I've only seen them a
couple times it's got one Mr Gordy one's
got the I like the Mr Gordy one yeah we
did a show about Haunting in Georgia a
while
back yeah yeah Zach said uh D'Angelo got
sent to prison back in 2021 I think
that's right yeah I couldn't remember if
he'd been convicted or not if he was
still like on trial cuz you know how
long the [__] trials Tak what's the
name of that
disc what do I search under haunting uh
I would just like look up well don't
look up a haunting in Connecticut
because it was a movie called that so
look up a haunting in Georgia I would
think because that I don't think there's
another movie called
that you know let's see if it's on cuz
The Haunting in Connecticut's see if
there's one on Amazon yeah look it
up might have be a haunting and then
like the uh pilot episode pilot that
might work too like a haunting pilot
episodes
yeah but like I said Ora Haunting in
Georgia Mr
Gordy something that won't get like a
million
unrelated you know
results yeah both on the same disc he
says Danny Rowling said the father from
from Haunting in Florida episode I just
saw in the 1983 film The Philadelphia
Experiment I'll be damned did we see
that
movie no I don't remember if we saw that
movie or not I know we did a show about
that and we watched a documentary about
it but I don't think I saw the fictional
movie about Haunting in Georgia yeah a
haunting double feature is what he
called it a haunting double feature yeah
a haunting in Georgia SL A Haunting in
Connecticut a haunting double pack
Haunting season three we already got
that we have the first six seasons on is
it it's a haunting right yeah yeah yeah
not the haunting that's something else a
haunting double feature yeah that's the
name of it yeah I mean you might be able
to find it that way you're on Amazon
right haunting of Connecticut Haunting
of Georgia there you go that's
$33 you can maybe get a used one though
on eBay that's what I'm saying they
don't have okay okay on
DVD they got it on DVD for $5 there you
go that's what he said yeah I'm gonna
get that right now I'm gonna get that
right now get that right now I'm G buy
that [__] right
now okay buying it right now yeah for
$5 on Amazon well it's actually $10 cuz
that's $4 delivery but I'm gonna get it
anyway but still he said it was cheaper
on eBay but yeah it's all right I just
get it with a [__] push of a butt
You' still have to pay shipping probably
yeah I wonder yeah yeah you still got to
pay shipping on
eBay
okay
okay well there you go now we're going
to have like some entertaining [__] to
watch yeah like I said I think we've
done shows on both of those but like a
long time ago we could do a revisit
though man we need to think of like a
movie to watch this weekend to talk
about on Monday we'll find something
yeah
speaking of
Amazon I just ordered today our wedding
rings we didn't even think about
it CU that's how [__] organized we
are I didn't think about it like before
we went to the courthouse or anything
like that and she's like oh you got new
rings and we're like oh yeah we should
probably do that so it's only like what
two months later more than two months
later so I just ordered some rings today
so they'll be here Sunday they're nice I
hope they fit
we'll see how that we'll see how that
goes my good that it's like oh [__] I
think I might have a bald spot on the
front of my hair but I can't tell if
it's that or one of my many cow licks
how many cow L you got
[Laughter]
Zach what are you doing answering uh
somebody I'm answering
um
s Ben Saudi Arab shave it all off just
in case that's what Tom did just shave
all your [__] hair off no I wouldn't
really recommend that depends on what
your build is I you know what I wish
that I looked good with no hair yeah
because my actual hair this a wig
clearly but um my actual hair is a pain
in the ass and I keep telling Tom all
the time I'm like man I wish I looked
good with no hair maybe shave it all off
maybe in a couple years you know what I
mean the the the progress you're making
can like the sides and the back are
shaved but it's still long on the so it
can still look normal if it has to the
thing is is that to look good bald you
got to be very trim you got to be lean
or muscular you cannot have a fat head
uh you can't have a fat body and be bald
it if you do that it doesn't look as
good as a lean
person that's what I found
like I shaved it off because I I was
losing weight and I could and my hair
wasn't all that good anyway so I said
[__] it I'm going to shave my head off
once I shaved it it looked better when I
grew beard along with it it looked even
better so ball with a beard that's
that's really now I wouldn't have tried
to rock this when I was younger you get
to a certain
age where you look better like this than
if you try to like be clean shaving with
long hair or whatever it
doesn't as a Young Man 's game I mean it
depends on the person obviously yeah
what your look is but it's a young man's
game if you ask
me it's better to just be [__] real
minimalist and [__] military and
rugged
looking [__] once you get older
rugged Tom yeah yeah well don't try to
be pretty you ain't going to be pretty
you're [__] ugly you're old all
right you just better be in good sh just
got to roll with it you better be in
good [__] you better look [__] tough
yeah you I'm talking about men I'm not
talking about women women don't really
it's women is a totally different game
yeah it is totally totally different
game but you woman could stay hot all
into her 70s if she plays her card right
look at [__] Cassandra Peterson also
known as as as elvir she looks [__]
great she's 73 74 most young dudes would
hit and you know she earned that though
she stayed in shape she's probably not
natural she definitely went under the
knife she's had facial work done I mean
sometimes you got it
you have to you know she's 70 something
years
old but uh you just tighten up jawlines
and [__] tighten up around the ears a
little bit and it [__] makes a hell
of a
difference
um [__] she's a good-looking old lady
um there are some L old ladies in their
70s in porn that [__] look old but
they're [__] like wicked witches man
they're [__] kind of hot like [__]
oh what's her name uh uh Sally D'Angelo
was that the one you showed me yeah she
her and that other old lady in the tub
yeah yeah with that one dude yeah and
that other old lady actually works with
Amy she's available yeah yeah that other
old lady and she's kind of a hot old
lady too but not she's not as old as uh
Sally D'Angelo and Sally D'Angelo looks
like something like out of a Disney
movie like the wicked witch that's kind
of awesome though yeah she's skinny got
big old boobs and [__]
real Wicked you know she sexual looking
though you well that's the thing and
particularly in porn but just in regular
life too yeah it's like whatever you
kind of got if you got something you
like you just kind of have to work that
look you know what I mean it it doesn't
have to be like classically beautiful or
it doesn't have to be anything like that
but if you have like some kind of unique
features yeah like you need to like play
that up right D'Angelo her her feature
was she had just this wicked looking
evil kind of face yeah and she just
rolled with it big old fake titties and
skinny and 70 something years old with a
[__] real rough voice hey you come
here you you aine she's just real
aggressive she sees like your your like
chain smoking alcoholic ant yeah yeah
yeah yeah which which has its own appeal
yeah that that was her role and get in
here yeah yeah like you lick it that's
right you lick
it [__] wild you know yeah he showed
me this one that was like it was her and
this other old lady yeah abusing that
black dude in and was there was like a
real young he was probably like what in
his late 20s early 30s something like
that I can't I can't really remember
about 24 25 yeah he was pretty young
yeah like this really big dick black
dude and he's like in a bathtub and
these two ladies are just kind of
working him over they're just working
him over yeah and I was just like oh my
God this it was very entertain I I was
entertained yeah in I was entertained
yeah they were having a good time like
talking to each other like all the [__]
they were going to do and yeah it's
probably Sally's husband recording it
all he's one fuing f it was super funny
she's she's been in the
industry but Amy did a scene with the
other girl the other old lady she's cute
too she's according to Bill she's just
this really laid-back funny old hippie
chick yeah she'll want to smoke some
weed and see that's what I mean that's
why you can't like just [__] on old
people across the board yeah show up
some old people are super cool show up
in her little hippie outfit with
mushrooms on it and [__] you know doing
porn they're just like yeah whatever
there's like the old old lady from
[__] Harold and mod yeah like that
kind of old lady a lot hotter though we
I know but it's like we like that kind
of old ladies you know what I
mean those two old ladies were in good
shape um the another one that was that
looks great is um the girl was from in
from Beyond you you know who she is
you're you you follow her you're you're
one of her fans yeah Barbara kampton
Barbara kampon Barbara Crampton looks
great she's what she's she's gorgeous
she's in her 60s she still gorgeous late
60s Maybe I don't know how old she is
she might not be that old but you know
she's in her 60s she's got to be she was
smoking hot when I was in high school
and it from Beyond movie she doesn't
look that much different to be honest
with you I mean you can tell she's older
but well she got a little more
voloptuous not yeah it's really not a
huge difference she's cute as [__] like
I'm on her Instagram yeah and she's
always like posting pictures of you know
herself like various horror conventions
and stuff and she's always making like
the same like cute face she's always
like yeah and it's like it's adorable
like every time I see it women women
women can stay attractive for a long
time uh just as long as life isn't
beating them down they don't have a [__]
ton of kids that are beating them up
constantly and [__] you know yeah
that helps yeah motherhood [__]
accelerates things a lot just because
the stress you know well and you're
always tired [__] kids keeping you
awake all the time even when they're
adult when you're an adult you're
worried about them and [__] fing and and
the hormones change in both men and
women when they have kids even guys when
he uh starts having kids his
testosterone levels will start to
decline and it's Nature's Way of keeping
him tied to that woman cuz they don't
want him wandering that's what nature
had yeah you got to [__] help help
the kids yeah you made those right you
got to help [__] take care so it
starts getting rounder and rounder and
mellower and
mellower uh if you don't start injecting
it like I do but the thing is I never
had any kids so I always had that edge
that not that you know of I know but the
thing is is if you don't know about them
that's [__] fast life strategy that
doesn't affect your hormones you just
double down your [__] test your test
level stay good until you're like
[__] 40 and then they start catching
up with you although I held out [__]
good while I really started feeling it
maybe around 43 44 I could feel that my
[__] was starting to slow down I didn't
know what the hell was
wrong by the time 48 came around man I
could [__] I didn't feel
good um going on HRT Chang the game man
it was just well honestly I think it's
good that you kind of talk about it
because I think some dudes maybe don't
know you didn't know I didn't know what
it was yeah um and I didn't know uh it
really didn't I didn't really think
about it so it's just kind of like feels
like the hand of death man [__] right
and like you were going like that and I
was just kind of like oh my God what's
the matter with you I hit male menopause
andropause Andre I thought it was some
[__] I did no menopause cuz that's how
women do we think everything is our
fault a lot of [__] that's happened in
these famous dudes throughout history
like why' he die so much like like Elvis
man that's the symptoms of
androgena that's why he he was
complaining well first of all he was
getting older he got addicted to pills
that's suppressive so that will suppress
your natural testosterone production he
started putting on weight getting
depressed he thought death was coming
for him and and then it's like a bad
it's like a feedback it's hard to get
out of
and they didn't know what was wrong with
him [__] yeah [__] he was living
his whole life on a high on a [__]
testosterone high he was constantly the
center of attention he was the [__]
Alpha [__] dog for a long time he
started feeling bad he didn't know what
it was like to feel bad and then it
starts [__] cascading on him and
um it really started when he hurt his
leg he started taking they gave him
painkillers that just accelerated it so
he trying to [__] take painkillers
and be a rock star at the same time he's
putting on weight and getting depressed
and dude [__]
died at the time of his injury if they
just [__] [__] the painkillers man
just [__] bump him up with a bunch of
test he'd have lost a bunch of weight
felt great [__] been right back where
he was you know well hindsight's 2020
yeah well they didn't know back then no
that's what I'm saying they had they had
it synthesized and everything they knew
about anabolics they knew about hormones
uh they knew about
testosterone but only very few people
knew what it was for they had
testosterone available before they knew
what what to do with it they originally
wanted to use that [__] to
treat
um uh what do they call
it uneven urine
stream you know what I mean for like the
prostate minc
prostate that's what they wanted to
treat it for before they didn't know
anything they didn't know what
testosterone actually did strange when
you think about it but um the wording of
the wording in the advertisements for
the early synthetic testosterone meant
that they the wording mean means that
they were going to treat it for
Urology yeah that's [__] nonsensical
yeah it'll it'll it'll yeah it'll fix
that but it has a much wider applic got
much better applications man I fuing
hell
yeah Zach says Isabelle Luper is almost
70 and I I think and looks amazing I
actually thought she was older than that
and honestly I always thought she was
super [__] sexy holy [__] I love her
um what was that movie she was in oh the
piano
teacher that was like one of the hottest
[__] movies ever I loved that [__]
movie I need to watch that again now
that I'm thinking about
it but yeah I love her I love Isabelle
bear wasn't she in
wasn't she in one of Halal Harley's
movies I feel
like I always been a big fan of Halal
heartley movies actually my ex-husband
got me into those but they're awesome
and I don't really hear people talking
about them anymore but I always like
really liked T Harley amateur is
probably my favorite but he did a lot of
good ones simple men was good um what
was that other one that he did Henry
fool that was that was pretty
good but like I said amateurs my
favorite
um yeah Jane Seymour too yeah I haven't
seen her but yeah it's totally possible
like I
said you're going to need surgery you
can't just you're going to need surgery
probably and hormones and various other
things you can't
just oh I'm just going to age without
doing anything it's like that doesn't
some people it works out I guess if
you're lucky but most of the time it
doesn't High Desert said the knife
hasn't been kind of Madonna I think yeah
she she got a little carried away I'm
I'm going to say she's in a new movie I
think it's called substitute flesh you
should review it for Monday I heard she
was in I had heard that that she was in
a new movie I don't know do I want to
watch that
maybe Bryce said I always get told the
thing that is most attractive about me
is my voice my girl loves my deep Gruff
voice which I wasn't aware of until she
pointed it out I think incels just don't
try well yeah that's probably it I mean
that's the thing everybody has something
about them or you know usually more than
one thing that's attractive to somebody
else but maybe they don't I don't know
maybe they don't think about it
or well if you got if you got a good
deep voice it's because you got de
decent test levels the [__] higher
your test levels the deeper that shit's
going to go like you know I could go go
down here like an old blues singer if I
want to you know you can I I can growl
it sounds like a [__] wild animal
Jenny loves it me big one yeah he does
make growling yeah when he gets all into
the yeah but my shit's [__]
supernaturally high I got like three
times a test of a [__] teenage boy
but uh lot lot of you know I've [__]
been looking at the whole manosphere and
he's talking about the incels incels is
dumb
they they don't understand what women
are and they don't know what men are uh
I think they just want to complain yeah
they their their main problem is that
they lack motivation and they they lack
Clarity they can't see the world for
what it
is if they did see the world for what it
is in the situation and the dating
situation for what it is they would have
to make a reaction to it to try to
compete in that well that would mean
you'd have to put out effort and these
[__] aren't going to put out
effort well they don't want to do that
so they just cry they're going to cry
putting out effort means diet exercise
discipline self-development and they
can't or something like I said makes
yeah yeah interest then you're going to
have to take risk go talk to some girl
that's a [__] oh she might say no
yeah yeah she might she might but she
might say yeah world's not going to end
though right if that happens or you can
just go out there and just go meet them
we've all been rejected yeah you know
what I mean it's not the end it's not
the end of the world it's really
not very few in cells they're not
involuntary cells but they're voluntary
they just don't know they made that
decision yeah they have voluntarily they
just not real they have voluntarily
removed themselves from the
game because they just refuse to see it
and they refuse to answer the challenge
a lot of it has to do with just [__]
infantalism they've been
coddled so life's been easy for them
they don't they that's all they know is
easy competing is hard self-development
is
hard self-development actually when you
really look at it the kind of
self-development that women would be
interested in is self-destructive
actually guys that are taking high risk
they're doing things that are dangerous
and surviving and then their their
powers grow over time and that's the
kind of that's the kind of guys that
women tend to be attracted to guys that
are kind of dangerous they're not
dangerous to them they're just dangerous
in general they're doing [__] that's
dangerous they're [__] climbing
mountains they're riding motorcycles
they're going to war they're fighting
they're [__] but they do creative
[__] too well that's what I mean it's
not just that it's everything everything
want it's somebody that's like I said
it's just somebody that's interesting
welled entertain right that's all you
don't have to like you know risk falling
off a mountain or nothing you don't have
to jump out of planes or nothing I don't
you know that's cool there's got to be
character but yeah you have to have some
kind of something like to offer somebody
women like men of status and doesn't
doesn't necessarily mean money no
they're broke they're are broke ass
Surfers [__] are hot as [__]
but they can surf
and there's some they got some kind of
social status and the girls like them a
certain kind of girl you know so it's
just well look at all the girls that
love broke ass artists for Christ's sake
or musicians yeah they'll support them
sure you know now there's some other
things involved in that they're
attractive well yeah that's probably an
issue too but a lot of these inels don't
even can't grasp
attraction all right they'll see a woman
go oh yeah I want that I'm looking and
she's like a nine or a 10 and I'm like
dude you're a three you'll never get
that not in the condition you're in now
you know you don't have any money and
you look like [__] what does she want
with you that's like me walking down
walking down the street I got Jen on my
arm and then I see some chick laying in
the gutter she's a bum she's pissed
herself and everything I'm go hold on
Jen I got to hit this you think that's
going to happen I'll be right back ain't
never going to happen no ain't never
going to happen that's pretty harsh Tom
well that's what it's like when she
looks at you she's like you know what
hold on I got to drop everything I get
hit this dude he's a three no ain't
going to happen man it's just yeah I
mean women only go out with with their
own kind or
better they'll they'll make a lateral
move over to a guy that's like at their
level or they'll be stunned by a dude
that's that they look up to he's got
more money maybe or he's better looking
or he's a combination of the two he's
just [__] amazing she'll go for that
too they don't go down they don't dat
down well as I told you like before I
met you like because
before I actually formerly met you I
used to see you at I bar all the time
yeah cuz I used to go there all the time
with my ex-husband and you were there
all the time and the first thing I
noticed about before I knew you I didn't
know if you had any money or nothing
like that I thought you were cool
because one you dress cool which a lot
of dudes don't uh you know you had a
really good a cool style that stood out
you could dance yeah which again a lot
of white dudes can't yeah just not being
an [__] just that's true
um and I also liked you seem to you had
a lot of friends yeah male and female uh
and you know a lot of people seemed to
like you and you were just very
gregarious and you were like outgoing so
you could tell you were like a good guy
because like a lot of people liked you
you know what I mean when I first met
jeny I didn't notice her cuz she was
married yeah didn't really notice her
although the second time I remembered
her yeah and she was cool I liked her
she was she was a cool chick she was
married though yeah so I didn't really
back then back
then but I think that was what I first I
first noticed cuz I was like well you
when she got single [__] changed yeah
she got singled and she [__] lost a
[__] ton of weight she show up she was
cute as
[__] so we started hanging out yeah but
we were still friends for like just a
long time yeah we' kind of go at each
other we'd [__] hit every now and
then but we were it wasn't wasn't a
thing we were just dating and hanging
out
and like I said I was but then later we
like people we like okay we'll do this
then like I said it was like it's kind
of hilarious like how it happened it was
just like not even a yeah not even a
conscious y thing and I never went on a
date with Jen never dated her not really
nope we just hung out and went to dinner
and did [__] together yeah like normal
people I [__] hated dates and most
dudes most players hate dates and most
[__] cool chicks hate dates too they
just [__] hate it that's a job
interview if you got to go on a job
interview you ain't going to get that
job you don't want to go out with that
girl if you got to go on a job and you
don't want to go out with that guy if
you got to go on a date date no if you
like that person you're just want to
spend time you know yeah and it just
seemed like that's kind of what happened
it's just kind of like we weren't cuz we
were still [__] other people at that
time cuz I was single you were single
and it's like we were kind of doing that
that but it's just like we kept hanging
out hanging out he's just like hey like
why don't you come over my house like
we'll go to the club and then you can
stay over and like you know [__] like
that so we just kept doing that yeah so
it was just like a until it was like
well why don't we just like live
together because we're always at each
other's houses yeah and then [__] we
became a thing and then everybody else
was like well [__]
finally everybody else saw it before we
did I guess I mean it was that kind of
situation
well
we had both got just gotten out of
marriages true so me and Jen were kind
of
like you know we we wanted to have fun
we wanted to have
relationships but you know didn't we
didn't want to get
married brought out the bat you know
like we wanted to have fun more anything
else and have make a lot of friends yeah
more of that so our relationship mostly
when it started off it's almost kind of
like business we were trying to conquer
the goth Market [__] with DJ and
[__] graphic designs
and get business going that way so we
had a common
goal we also wanted to become wellknown
yeah so it just started to build that
like that and um you become well known
when you know club
Owners if you get in good with the club
Owners then you're going to get welln
yeah I kind of feel like for a time yeah
we were kind of like the the probably
the most or among the most wellknown
people in the yeah in the oring yeah I
mean most people even if they didn't
know us personally like knew who we were
yeah all these main DJs we got them
their
gigs I got you realiz you realize that
right yeah yeah we got them their
gigs and like I said we don't I mean I'm
not yeah they're friends of ours too
bragging or nothing yeah just it it
happened naturally I mean I feel like
it's probably less now because we don't
go out as much and it's like you know
younger crowd is taking over but neither
does anybody else right of our you know
I mean still when we go out it's like ah
you know everybody's like well a lot of
the young a lot of the younger crowd do
they do not have the same
in-depth they don't have the same Roots
inside and club culture they're
online they're not as driven to go to
clubs as we
were cuz that was our social media
that's not their social media yeah goth
on on it's different they they just grew
up different yeah they're they're
they're goth on [__] Instagram we're
just kind of used to even though we're
online a lot too obviously cuz we're
kind of you know we're Gen X so we kind
of straddle Both Worlds I guess but we
kind of grew up in person having to go
someplace you had to go someplace yeah
like to hang out with people yeah
so uh so so we ended up doing that but
like I said I do a lot of online stuff
too but yeah well you have to it's part
of normal life now yeah that's what I
mean and like some people and I can't
you know you can't blame younger people
because that's all they know I mean they
grew up like that it's hard for us to
Fathom because we well I don't think
it's hard for us to Fathom because we
like I said we straddle Both Worlds like
I said we kind of grew up and there was
nothing but then we were like right at
the cusp cuz I think I was in my early
20s when the internet first started
taking off you know what I mean so I
lived like my youth without it but then
like my young adulthood and a like you
know we had it so it was just kind of
like exactly halfway in between so it
was kind of like a good I think it was a
good
um like era to live through a lot of
these new goth kids that are coming into
the club now actually are products of
the damn
lockdowns when all that covid stuff was
going on they were online learning music
learning about go culture and [__] they
were doing it online they're just
starting to come out
now yeah know so they didn't have the
same upbringing where well we've had a
lot of younger people come out they know
everything and they know everything like
they look like we wanted to look back in
the old days but we couldn't afford it
they look perfect and they know all the
band and they know all the old music
they know everything like that and it's
just like and they come out and they're
just kind of like oh well we heard this
was like the goth night and everything
so it's like they're just starting to
like come out to I mean they're young
they're like 18 1920 and uh and it's
[__] crazy to see cuz it's like they
look like a million times
better look like [__] because it takes
first of all the clothes weren't
available we could get it takes a you
could only see the fashion in person we
didn't have Instagram where you could
[__] do the homework and buy the [__]
and show up looking good and then
knowing all the bands finding all the
goth bands back in the day was hard
because there was no internet to [__]
search goth bands you just [__] had
to know who had albums right and [__]
look at the albums you know and uh then
you had to go to your local club and see
how everybody was dressing and look at
all the different clicks because there
would be you know industrial people more
go people death Rock people and these
kids show up ready to go [__] perfect
outfits I know they look fantastic God
damn you put damn you know you never
been to a club look at you that's
straight out of that's how I wish I had
looked back in the 80s like I couldn't
afford it straight out of [__]
specimen or [__] you know something
like that yeah they look fantastic yeah
they got the hair right and everything
everything shaved they're killing it
Mohawks shaved Mohawks with [__] big
old long the girls with big old long
sideburns and [__] stripes in the
[__] hair and it looks like looks
like [__] 1983 on [__] steroids
yeah it's great it's the way 1983 was
supposed to look but they you didn't you
couldn't get the clothes though yeah
like they weren't available like unless
you had a sew which I didn't yeah like
you could get stuff at thrift stores but
it didn't look exactly you know you kind
of had to Cobble some [__] together it
was yeah handmade stuff and really hard
to find
Boutique [__] that came out of some
[__] BDSM [__] store in London
yeah that's where a lot of the [__] like
I would have to save up to buy stuff
from like black rose in London or
something like that like I have to save
up all year to buy one thing yeah they'd
be like $250 $300 corsets back in the
'90s and 80s right like oh I really
wanted this velvet dress from Black Rose
and it's like I saved up all year for
that the [__] they would gouge the
[__] out of you and nowadays you can get
that same corset from [__]
60 crazy you could get awesome boots for
100 demonia boots for about a 100 you
know now the quality was a little bit
better pentag gagin and [__] were
[__]
Leather So they were a couple hundred
bucks and that's kind of demonia kind of
look like pentag gagin to me and then um
you still had new Rocks new rocks were
been around for a long time that's a
[__] 375 400 mine were what
375 something like that yeah but you've
had them for years they for you buy them
once and you got them forever yeah you
know and it's real good leather so if
anything goes wrong you can go take it
to a leather repair place and have it
repaired yeah put new they're like for
Life they're not they're like for Life
yeah they're not like some throwaway
thing right uh Oscar is here hey Oscar
what's up Jenny how about a review of
The Dan of the Daniel Fus uh film naked
oh I love that movie honestly I you know
what I think I might have it like on DVD
and I don't think I've reviewed it so I
might um yeah I really really like that
movie actually also how about The Cook
the Thief His Wife and Her Lover yeah
I've been wanting to do that one for a
long time too uh Tammy says uh talking
about what Bryce said um yeah he said
yeah I see I see what you mean by women
go up I thought it was money but it's
more my girl is from a rich family and
I'm not no they want other features not
necessarily money and then Tammy said
women can make their own money we don't
need a man for their money we want
personality character but you got to
man's got to pull his own weight though
you can't yeah you can't just be a bum
you can't be a bum they don't they don't
want somebody that's just going to sleep
on your couch and not even wash your
[__] dishes or anything like that for
Christ's sake you got to pull your own
weight yeah you got to do that but it's
not money I I kind of feel like a lot of
like dudes that are incels like we'll
use it as an excuse oh well chicks just
want money that is absolutely not the
case women are looking at a man's
overall score and in the overall men are
just looking at the woman's physical
score yeah one to 10 he's talking about
physical [__] like yeah they don't
really give a [__] about anything other
well they do they do is just that the
score that they're given is just based
on physicality yeah um because men are
very visual especially when it comes to
mate selection it's mostly visual um but
there's mitigating circumstances I've
been with some [__] hot ass [__]
women but they weren't worth this [__] I
was going to hit and but I was going to
hit until I got sick of it and I was
going to replace her with a woman I
could deal with didn't mean that she
wasn't an eight she was an eight still
an eight but I didn't like her right
okay it's just a man's mind works a
little differently because we don't have
to be around to raise the kid we can
just hit it and run that's the way most
of our ancestors did it back in the
[__] Bush you know in Prehistoric Age
KS you're programmed to hit it all
throughout history better looking she is
the more you want to hit it all right
and try to knock her up that's what your
that's what your instincts are trying
and then run away so you have no further
responsibility yeah if you don't like
her run Ron make her I'm not doing any
work [__] that yeah you make some
[__] lesser male [__] take care of
it you know yeah that's that that was
the and they doing it to to this day
dudes are doing that um but that's not
the same situation with the female
mating strategy they got a lot more to
lose yeah so their judgment is more
rounded the physicality is a factor his
personality if he's entertaining how
other people see him that's a factor
[__] also just like how she sees him
as a factor but it's only there's many
many factors that she's looking at it's
a lot more complicated it's more
complicated for them so everything's
more complicated with us sorry a dude
could not have a whole lot of money not
even be all that good looking maybe he
maybe a a dude would give him like the
score of like five which isn't bad okay
or six all right but he doesn't have a
lot of money but he's with a check that
you give a eight you how the hell do he
do that well it's because of all these
other mitigating circumstances yeah
heed he's got you know he's funny uh she
he's
trustworthy uh he's not a pushover he
does stand up for himself uh but he also
helps her uh it's a bunch of different
they have a lot in common they have a
lot in they hang out they have fun
similar goals right uh her friends like
him that's another thing so he's got
high status with her friends so there's
a bunch of different factors they're
factors that dudes don't even consider
because our
our our system that our program that we
inherited is very rudimentary yeah it's
just about [__] and running really
that's the basic run that was a song
that's the basic one is hit it get her
Knocked Up and Run that's by Liz far
that's the default now if you like her
you're going to stay that's the
difference and a dude will hit a chick
he doesn't
like somei will do that too but I've
always had a hard time yeah yes I've
actually heard women say they'll hate
[__] a dude they can't stand him I've
heard but I think that's I don't know if
that's a minority I have heard of like
women that would do that it's like oh my
God I hated this [__] dude so much
but I [__] him anyway because he was
hot well like one time yeah well I heard
the the way it was described to me by a
girl we know is that you hate the
[__] you he's hot but what you
want to do is you want to [__] him and
then dump him to P to to get [__] him
over yeah okay I get that that that's
how they're doing I get that they like
the sex but they're already planning to
[__] [__] this dude over cuz they
they can't stand him but he doesn't know
right that she can't stand him that's
dud are not super clued in to a lot of
the [__] that's going on in our minds
like I said we're very very complicated
well and the thing about it is that and
like some chicks can do that like I've
known some chicks that can do that I
have a hard time um I just can't really
get enthusiastic about and look I like
sex you know that but it's just kind of
like I can't get enthusiastic about a
dude I don't like yeah no matter how hot
they are I'm like if you're kind of a
douche I'm just it's not working for me
girl we know girl we know I ain't me
mentioning any name so but oh my God
she's gonna be she brought up no no
she's probably she brought up a [__]
thing that it's not just her it's
something that women do I have heard of
like I wouldn't I don't do this but I've
heard of other women that did this yet
cuz we're not all the same yeah but it
is female behavior and I did check up on
it and they go yeah they do do
that if a
woman is at a
club and she sees a dude she doesn't
really want to go out with
him but he'll kind of
do she likes him but she's not going to
keep him all right she will lower her
standards to sleep with that dude that
night cuz women also like one night it's
like one night stand she'll lower her
stand to sleep with that dude on a one
night
stand next week at the club not often
but I've done she sees another dude that
she likes she goes I like this
[__] she raises her standards
for him and if he doesn't meet those
standards because he's now a
disappointment yeah she's like oh [__]
that dude blows him off so she [__]
the dude she didn't like and she turned
down the one she did like because she
didn't cuz that dude but see that makes
total sense though it only makes sense
to a woman to a dude it makes total
sense that makes no sense to a dude she
should at
least that was the dude she liked she
should have at least [__]
him well should she have she [__] a
dude she didn't like yeah but she just
wanted some
dick why didn't she like you would think
that that men would understand that of
all no no no no no men do not understand
that at all women also sometimes just
want dick they don't really care about
the person that's contrary that's
contrary I said I don't do that but
other women do totally contrary to
everything that a guy's about a guy if
the girl doesn't quite meet his
standards but he wants to have sex with
he'll have sex with her if he likes this
girl but she doesn't quite meet she
doesn't she didn't quite meet the
standards you thought she was going to
be you'd still have sex with her yeah
cuz you like her right cuz you like her
you like that you don't like that one
that much but you like this one well I
mean she's not as good as you thought
she was you probably like this one okay
yeah and you're just kind of like hey
I'm kind of horny tonight and it's like
you know this dude's not fantastic but
he's okay like he'll do if she likes the
dude she raises the standards to the
point where he doesn't make it and she
doesn't [__] the no no no I don't know
about that but the thing about it I I do
see that though because you might raise
your standard because well you're like
okay well you take this dude more
seriously yeah you're taking him
seriously so you want to see the other
dude you weren't taking him seriously
cuz you're just like yeah
you took that one seriously so you but
this one if you're kind of teaching him
taking him seriously it's like oh okay I
actually like this one yeah let's see
how this develops okay see this is the
female this is the female logic makes
total sense I'm going to let y'all
handle that I'm going let you guys
handle that I go to the restroom because
that doesn't make any goddamn sense it
makes no sense to to from a male
perspective well well maybe your
perspective is wrong did you ever think
about that of course not cuz that's the
default apparently
the way dudes think uh have you guys
ever reviewed silence the Lambs you know
what I don't think we did and I was
thinking about that the other day
because I've seen Silence of lamb so
many times that I probably have that
[__] thing memorized and I saw that
it was for free on one of the streaming
services the other day and I was like oh
my God you know what one of these days
we should probably review Silence of the
Lambs but I don't know we probably will
like I said I've seen it so many times
though I saw it in the theater when it
first came out with my
mom and this is this is how good the
movie was halfway through the movie I
started having to pee so bad like you
guys don't even know and I I would not
go to the bathroom like the whole time
cuz I didn't want to miss anything and I
was by the end of it I was like [__]
dying I thought I was going to [__]
wet my pants but I just did not want to
leave because the movie was so good
that's how good the movie was I saw in
the theater with my mom back in
um
yeah Bryce says I think a lot of red
pillow people are just ignorant uh they
don't even talk to women I think yeah
it's like I said I think it's more a
case
of maybe they they have a thing where
they've just had everything handed to
them or everything's been easy for them
and so anything that's kind of like
challenging or anything that's like you
know has to expend any effort they just
don't want to do it um and because they
don't want to do it um they'll just like
make excuses you know it's always
somebody else's fault they always kind
of
externalize why they're not successful
like it's always somebody else's fault
it's never their fault I think that's
kind of what it is a lot of dudes do
that though I kind of feel like they do
kind of externalize when bad things
happen they're just always kind of like
yeah that was everyone was against me
you know what I mean which no but you
know sometimes yeah sometimes that
happens but not
usually
but you're just like so funny Tom every
time I try to explain things to you your
always like well that doesn't make any
sense it makes no sense it does it does
it does make complete sense it makes
complete sense
so you [__] some dude that you don't
really like you actually lowered your
standards to [__] that dude and then you
do you do like the dude that you do like
you don't [__] it because you raised
your standards up too high it makes no
sense like I said you want to see if
this dude will meet your expectation
yeah okay because you actually like that
person so you take him more
seriously you're well no what actually
happened well yeah but you think that
like well you know it's a possibility
you could have a relationship with this
person this other dude over here like I
said you just wanted some D1 night so
you weren't like thinking of like a
relationship with that person this is
what really happens because I saw this
happen in person in the
Army dude was [__] uh two guys I was
in the army with we were hanging out
with [__] one of the local [__]
places that we used to go all the time
is outside Fort
Campell Dude shows up one of the one of
the girls that was kind of a regular
hanging up hanging out there he says man
[__] I finally [__] uh got me a
girlfriend
he's he said really says yeah [__]
took me [__] three or four weeks to
[__] go out with there [__] I
finally went out with her and
um
[__] I saw who it was she was talking
he who he was talking about so then they
were starting to hang
out and I guess about a week or so later
they were in there hanging
out and another dude that we know showed
up and [__] he did he also say hey I
got a girlfriend no no okay no what he
did was that's how I thought that was
gonna end [__] he he was he tells him
he goes oh you going out with her and he
goes yeah and he's like yeah and he goes
yeah I [__] her he says you [__] her
he says yeah I [__] her on her first
date he was like really and the dude
that we're talking about was [__]
like he's a scuzzbag you [__] he's and
he goes you didn't [__] her he say yeah
I did and he [__] described her
described what she looked like where
what she looked like clo and [__] she
knew who he was and she anyway because
he found that out the dude was [__]
like doubling down he was she was taking
him seriously so she was putting him
different you're putting them in
different categories is all it is it's
like like I said I would have thought
that dude's going to understand no dude
number two dumped her just says oh okay
[__] she first date she [__] [__]
her and he jumped her but see every
that's the thing like I I don't know
maybe because we're a lot more complex
or something but it's just kind of like
there's a lot of different factors going
into each thing I feel like you can't
really judge I don't know if you can
like really judge cuz look you know I've
done some questionable [__] yeah when I
was out at clubs and drunk and lonely
and things like that that I would not
repeat if I was given
but it's like I would hate to think that
some would like hold that against oh my
God you slept with that dude know I me
kind of like what it was is
that dude [__] her for nothing and but
the the the the second guy was spending
all kinds of money on her and whining
and dining her when he didn't have to he
could have just [__] her for nothing
like he did the other guy so yeah but
maybe not the way he looked at it right
but like but that's not he's getting
sloppy seconds off this
way yeah but women are going to look at
it like this is a new person like you're
going to it's this is a whole different
situation yeah you know what I mean well
the guy looks at it like she liked that
scumbag more than the [__] good guy
because she [__] him for free but the
good guy had to pay right but maybe well
like I said maybe she don't like that
guy and like I said I would have thought
the dudes would understand like [__]
some skank you don't like just cuz she's
hot no like women do that too yeah he
didn't understand it I wouldn't
understand it either I'd be like yeah
[__]
her I don't know man yeah I'd be like
yeah [__] her then Y is such simple
things I got to pee talk talk about
something interesting but not that
interesting because I don't want to miss
anything okay let's see I'm going to go
read the [__] U
comments
Bryce says it's definitely different to
how men think but it makes sense I will
sleep with anyone as long as my girl's
okay with it but I will only commit to
my girl yeah
well yeah and then then he goes but a
lot of guys would think that he got
ripped off at that that happens they
feel like someone else and got it for
free that they had to pay full price
exactly so there you go you got
it in his mind and that was how I
interpreted it too at that time and I
was maybe
about I was guess I was probably about
23 22 23 the scumbag dude got it for
free but then the higher Echelon guy who
was
[__] Theon guy who was who's a better
looking guy he was a better guy uh he
had to pay for it you know he had to he
had to jump through all the hoops and do
all the work and the other guy just got
it for nothing so when he saw when when
his but and you see the thing is I
didn't really blame the scumbag guy for
telling the other guys because we we all
served together and and so he was
protecting his bro he was like she's
making you do all that man that I got
that for free that's a hoe and he's like
oh okay so and I was like yeah yeah dude
you don't want that and so he he he
dumped her because of that and it's like
like you said because that one dude got
it for free and the other dude had to
pay for it so that means she likes but
in the mind of a man she likes him less
cuz she had to pay that's not how it
works
though that's that's how it works but
see I'm just saying that if dudes want
to be successful with women it would
behoove them to understand how women
think yeah um you know if you if you
just hit it and quit it like if a woman
does that like I said I don't usually
I've done it but not often uh it's not
my favorite method obviously but um
because I'm just not that kind of person
but other people are no judgment so um
some people will do that but usually
they'll just do like I said it's just
like ah I was just lonely that night I
just wanted I didn't really like him all
that much but whatever like he was hot
or you know he just struck my fancy that
night or whatever and it's just kind of
like I don't really want to see him
again though you know what I mean um D
dudes do that too so
I don't really see any difference there
but the thing about it is that sometimes
they'll do that just as just random [__]
it's very different for the guy right
but the thing about it here's the
difference but the thing about it is
kind of a double standard though because
no it's not you don't think no all right
I'm going to go because with the guy
with the guy the entry is the same in
other
words with the woman she increased the
difficulty on the guy that she liked to
where he she increased the difficulty on
them if she liked him she should have
decreased the difficulty to get him to
get him to come in that's the way a guy
would have done it so don't don't yeah
you have to understand how women work
but my advice to your other guys don't
really you don't want to play into that
kind of thinking like yeah you know you
should know how they are
but
no she [__] a dude easily that she
doesn't like but then the guy that she
likes she raises the standards and makes
it more difficult for him no that
doesn't make that's totally contrary to
male
thinking if some chick's making a hit on
me and she's [__] fugly I don't
really want to go out with her I'm GNA
raise the difficulty on her try to get
rid of her but she might [__]
overcome it and go like okay
she she doesn't look like much but she
might be fun so I'm going go with her
all right but if she's [__] hot oh
there's not going to be any pricey entry
we're going to [__]
yeah yeah okay we're going to do this so
that is not equivalent the the between
male and female that's that's the
opposite that's the opposite thinking is
there's no male equivalent to what she's
saying like I said I don't I don't
really um I've never done that yeah um
so it's not but I get it like when you
explain that to me I was just kind of
like oh yeah okay like that made sense
to me but I've never done that
personally yeah so yeah well I'm just
saying that and that's another thing I
think a lot of like these incel type
dudes they think of women are all the
same or we're all like a hive mind or
something which is absolutely not the
case like they see dudes as individuals
but they somehow don't see us as
individuals the problem is like I said
I've never done that like you're describ
problem the problem is is is is thinking
that males men and women are running off
of different mating programs they've
inherited them through natural selection
okay now Society then modifies them
um
so and it's because the situation that
guys are in are very different than the
situation that girls the females are in
so it's a different criteria that
they're that they're going that they're
going
through but they're not equivalent to
one another they're they're
different and you know maybe that's a
good thing but you the dudes should
understand the criteria that women are
going are using well at least understand
that we're not coming at from the same
mindset that you're coming at it and
like I said you can't think of everyone
as a hive mind either because everyone's
an individual yeah like I said you know
I understand like when you explained
that to me like when you said about that
situation like it made sense to me like
from the women's point of view like why
she would do that but I've never
personally done that and that's never
you understand from the guy's point of
view that he's like oh [__] that no I do
understand it from the guy's point of
view yeah but I'm just saying that um I
don't I just I I don't know like I guess
I'm kind of uncom with cuz I kind of
feel like there's this thing where like
the male point of view is kind of like
the default no and like when the women's
point of view comes up everybody's like
oh it's weird or it's unnatural or it's
hysterical or whatever so it's just kind
of like it's just two ways of looking at
the same
situation neither one of them is right
or wrong necessarily it's just two ways
of looking at the same thing I disagree
that the male point of view is the
default especially
nowadays well it's gotten better
nowadays the female point of view is the
default in the culture um
um I think the females are in general
dominant over the over the males
especially the young the younger
ones um the thing is what I'm trying to
say is I'm trying trying to say the
problem is is then when you you as a man
are thinking that your default system or
that you're thinking that your system is
Flawless there is flaws in the male
programming but there's also flaw
there's also flaws in the female
programming um so a woman's going to run
into problems if if she thinks that her
[__] don't stick well no one's
perception is going to um humans are
imperfect well and no one's no one's
perception is going to uh you know play
across every single person because
everyone's different you know so you
kind of have to approach each person
because you don't know if that person
like I said we're not all Hive Minds
yeah so and we're not all the same it's
like oh men do this women do this like
in General but individuals are a lot
different
my from my
experience women that liked me made it
easy for me okay they didn't make it
harder well I certainly did what's
that you did make it easy well I don't
know did I yeah I thought I did yeah
yeah but that well I don't know if I'd
say it's easy but I made it obvious you
made it obvious I made it obvious yeah I
didn't play any games cuz I'm not in
that actually and uh I'm very upfront
person the thing is though that in
general those were the types that I
selected in general um if they were up
to Snuff there was a lot of them that
were not up to Snuff they're like that I
get Telegraph signals all the time even
even though I'm married you know
recently I'll get signals at the club
but the thing is is that you know I'm
not available and they're not stuff
anyway um he's a [__] magnet it just
[__] just happens Tom's a [__] magnet
[__] just happened you still are well
it's an older crowd of women too that's
true all right it's not the same yeah he
gets women fogging up on him all the
time ones yeah although I have dudes
fogging up on me yeah it's both of
us but um probably not as many as women
[__] up on you but you women can get
away with things because that's true
they're not as they're not as much of a
because they're not a threat and uh you
yeah and I'm not sitting there guarding
you you know what I mean [__] um yeah
like I said you go lot of guys are
afraid to talk to you probably cuz they
don't know what I would do yeah you go
to the bathroom though and all bets are
off yeah depending on where we are
mannequins well yeah at Barbarella it's
fine because I know everybody there and
mannequins they're waiting for for that
they're waiting for an in okay he's gone
go see I know I see some of them doing
it you can see it in their face yeah
yeah yeah let's see if I can get an in
but they're super obvious they don't
know us
though be Slicker come on yeah I can
read your I can read your body language
yeah barbarell they all know us so they
don't they don't they don't [__] around
like I said I like it much better there
because it's a much safer environment we
know everybody there and everybody knows
us everybody knows the situation nobody
hits on you nobody gropes you it's
awesome yeah you can just dance in peace
and you can dance all Spazzy if you want
and like nobody will say a word to you
it's awesome I don't get jealous and I
mean as long as the guy's long as the
guy is uh uh [__] tactful and uh he's
cool about it he he can say what he
wants but he starts grabbing you're
gonna get [__] up well yeah then I'm
gonna punch you right in your face and
then Tom's going to punch you right in
your face [__] up when he comes back
from the grab her ass and he he he lived
to regret it I'll [__] grab your ass
by the [__] throat doesn't matter how
big you were he was like 6'1 or 6'2 and
that was some cowardly [__] that dude
pulled my back my back was turned yeah I
was just dancing minding my own [__]
business I'm 185 lbs but I'm also
[__] 12% % body fat you and you know
I'm I didn't even have time to react I
was just like hey what the [__] I'm only
5'6 but that's the numbers of a [__]
leopard okay I don't have the teeth and
the claws of a leopard but I was on
Trend at that time but [__] it I thought
I was a werewolf and holy crap that dude
thought I was a werewolf too he probably
did [__] had his throat and I got to
say like if I'm drunk enough then I'll
[__] step on your neck too
yeah I'm pretty nice when I'm sober but
like the drunker I get if somebody [__]
me I'm like oh my God I'm gonna kill
this person yeah you know what I mean so
I'm lucky I haven't going to getting
back to what I was talking about and I
only went out with girls that liked me I
didn't really pursue girls that didn't
like me I'm not one of these purs well
you didn't have to yeah I'm not one of
he's pursuing my type [__] you
don't like you you were always like up
your armpits in [__] Tom listen to her
no you
were it wasn't that bad I mean it wasn't
that good I wish it was that good but it
wasn't that good I did have to work for
it and but they I had female friend I
think I to me to be honest I think
that's the most attractive thing about
you that was one of the most attractive
things I found about you you had a lot
of female friends that you did not sleep
with yeah I had a lot of female friends
because and that is somebody that
genuinely likes women like as people
yeah like you see them as people that's
a very positive well I came from [__]
all male dominated [__] societies
military and [__] law enforcement
type [__] police type [__] there's all
[__]
dudes you get to know dudes real well
all right uh they're not mysterious to
you women are more mysterious I like
them you know I like women I like women
now they're are bad women well no one's
denying that there are bad women there's
bad people all around but no and then
there were some women that are bad but
that doesn't mean you're not going to
[__] them you know that's another thing
too they're naughty women I like naughty
too uh
there were women Jen saw me do it before
we were a thing going out with a girl I
know she's naughty I know I'm not GNA be
able to keep that but I'm gonna get it
you know what I mean I'm gonna ride it
like a ride in Disneyland when it's
there as long as it's there I'm gonna do
it you know what I mean [__] but I I
didn't have any unrealistic expectations
I came from a [__] kind of a
background of doing that kind of stuff
you know uh it wasn't always about
relationship you know it was lot of it
was just entertainment yeah you didn't
take a lot of it super seriously no no I
took you a lot of seriously but we were
friends see yeah so it was a different
situation I think that's but that was
the Genesis of how we became a couple
it's because we were friends yeah I
trusted you I made sure I could trust
you because we were friends for a long
time yeah you
know man there' be [__] chicks
[__] calling me when I'm in the car
with Jen and the girl wanted to kill her
[__] I know you I'm talking about I
know who you're talking about started
with the c I know you're talking about
yeah and I'm like what the [__] me and
Jenna looking at each other while she's
she was a little bit of a star she was
gonna [__] go to my house she said
she was I'm going to your house I'm
coming to your house right now I'm
coming to your house right now and I
would and I said but I'm I'm in the car
I'm I'm going she now we weren't a thing
at this point but we were kind of a
thing like we hung out all the time yeah
so we're in the car I think we were in
the McDonald's drive-thru or something
we were coming back from the club Kaylee
was in the car with us
R and um she called you yeah I'm coming
to your house right now she demanded she
Furious that I was hanging out with Jen
oh my God and the thing is is that she
wasn't my girlfriend this girl we're
talking about she wasn't my girlfriend I
didn't even date her I went home with
her one night and you didn't even [__]
her no
no I heard I heard that I heard that
story had retold that story I didn't
realize it that I had left J you left me
there and was at my house I my [__] was
all at your house I forgot about that
because I brought my stuff over cuz we
drove to the club together I brought all
my [__] early which I did often back
then even though we weren't going out
yeah I would usually stay at his house
cuz his house was a lot closer to the
club than mine was so I would bring my
[__] to the and I would get ready at his
house you know we would both get ready
together then we' go out in his car yeah
and then we would go back and we talking
to her other friend though so I thought
they were going to hook up that night so
it didn't really bother me and for some
reason I don't remember how I left the
club I think I was I think she said get
in a car I think this what she said get
in a car that sounds like her yeah get
in a car she's a little forceful yeah
and I was like but not in a good way
yeah he's like get in the car and I was
think I was out on that patio and and I
I probably just you probably were and
then you texted me and told me and I was
like [__] all my stuff is at your car
and like I'm stuck here now so I had to
go I had to go stay I had to go stay at
that dude's house she she told me to get
in the car cuz I I I made Big D cuz we
weren't really going out anymore me and
that guy yeah I remember what it was now
that I've been drinking I remember what
it was she tricked me she tricked me
yeah
Sheed she said get in the car let's go
for a ride and I was like all right I'm
sure so I got in the car with a [__]
drink and everything this [__] man and
I thought she just met going going for a
ride down the main strip you know down
orange a like you thought you were just
gonna she blow freeway I was she was
taking me home right that's how it
happened that sounds like some [__] she
would do cuz this [__] holy [__] man
she was like gun how long was that that
she was like going after you like that
about a year like I about a year holy
crap they were up on a stage together
one time everybody was dancing they has
like there these little boxes that you
can dance on and [__] she was up
there dancing and [__] that girl got
up next to her they started fighting and
the club [__] trying to push other and
Jen [__] pushed her ass off that
thing though man it was [__] no no no
that's not what happened you what was it
you did I don't remember what happened
was I was standing up there minding my
own business yeah just leaning against
the wall like on the box but out of
everyone's way so I was against the wall
so this [__] like I said and I I don't
hate a lot of people well I don't know
if that's true but I don't I don't hate
a lot of people but holy crap she got on
my [__] last nerve right and um
and she was oh my God she was just like
completely she was always there and she
was just always like stalking and she
was always like around and you could
tell that she was always trying to get
your attention like you remember that
one time at iar when we're just like
hanging out in the corner like we always
did yeah this might have been after we
started going out I'm not really sure
but she started doing like a pole dance
yeah on like two or three feet in front
of it like very obviously like just Dow
grind and everyone's like what the [__]
is this [__]
cuz that's not really the type of thing
that you would do at this club um so
everyone's just like what the [__] she's
not a bad looking girl she was she's not
she's beautiful actually she just had
funny I could be an [__] and say
she's like an Ugo but she's not she's
not she had funny taste in clothing she
kind of looked like something from a
[__] [__] New Order video or
something um she I always thought she
was beautiful she that's that pains me
to say but she is she is beautiful she
had a she got a boyfriend took her way
off to Germany and [__] she's back now
but she hasn't come to clubs yeah I
haven't seen her yeah thank God I think
the last time I saw her was a couple
years ago that was a long time ago I
think she came to iar before it moved
that's all blown over that was a long
time ago she's probably not like that
anymore she's not coming to the clubs
well thank God she not coming to Club
but no what happened we didn't start
fighting it this was not my doing well
okay so I'm just leaning against the
wall like I said minding my own business
she comes up on the um the raise part
the
stage and she walks by me and very
deliberately just like in [__] high
school goes like this yeah that's right
that's right I remember that I remember
that I was watching like with her elbow
and I was like [__] really yeah I
remember like what the [__] how old are
we come on and I was kind of drunk and I
was just kind of like all right that's
enough because like I said at this point
you have to think I got these hot chicks
fighting over well at this point it's
been like more than year of this [__]
just constantly in our faces she's just
in our faces like all the time we're
we're there at the club we're dancing
there she is she want to take hey look
at me she want to take no for an look at
me and I'm just like really really
please go away she want to take no for
an one time she brought her annoying ass
sister who was just as annoying as her
they were just like and they were just
like up in our faith like the whole time
you they were like pushing you against
the wall mhm like hey why my sister said
and they pushed me against the wall my
sister says you don't like her I was
like I [__] don't yeah yeah and you
clearly are just like her yeah so like
don't get all please don't get all up in
my face like that so yeah so she did
that yeah and like I said it just all
culminated yeah because the fact that
she had done this very obvious oh whoops
like that kind of [__] I was like oh my
God I'm just not so I just grabbed her
neck I just went like that and I pushed
her against the railing yeah and I just
I didn't push her off there's railing I
just pushed her against the railing and
squeezed her neck and just looked right
in her face yeah I remember that I
remember that [__] [__] and I was
just like not get the [__] off like what
like why yeah please not get the [__]
off and then she went to Lee the
bartender and
bitched and Lee told her to get lost and
Lee said oh well who was it that did oh
it was that Jenny girl oh piss off he he
didn't like her speaking of Lee is did
Lim Lee ever show up okay
yeah but that was what happened because
like I said nobody in that place that
worked there liked that liked that girl
she got into too much [__] she was
trouble and uh she was constantly
whining about somebody or other yeah
and Lee used to tell us all the time
because I used to kind of [__] about
her sometimes like man this [__] she's
like always in her [__] face man she
just won't go away yeah and like Le's
like oh my God I hate that [__] [__]
and like so she complained she's like oh
my God she tried to kill me she said
yeah
that's what Lee told me later she tried
to kill me yeah he didn't triy to kill
you well he's like well who tried to
kill you oh that that Jenny girl and
he's just like get the [__] out of here
get the [__] out of here so I yeah it
yeah I didn't hurt her I don't think no
I didn't hurt her she walked out I
didn't kick her ass or Nothing But like
I wanted to I wanted to kill her cuz I
was like I was sick of her [__] [__]
cuz like I said it
was it wasn't just that night yeah it
had been like more than a year and I'm
pretty patient I'm pretty tolerant I'm
was just kind of like I just roll my I'm
like look it's not worth it it's like
she's being a pain in my ass but I'm
just going to ignore it so I ignored it
for a really long time but that night I
was like you know what no I'm not going
to ignore it anymore that's what I
said Bryce is talking about how valuable
it is uh valuable skill it is if you're
a guy you can just make female friends
and I think that's that's really rare
and I think like I said that was one of
things that stood out to me that well
and you have a lot and I'm going to say
that you have a lot of female friends
that are hot yeah that you have not
slept with yeah because you just like
them
yeah yeah you know well and I and I and
I liked that about you they were all
good women right now Bryce also says
something about those red pill guys when
he says they don't really know how to go
back and say they didn't know how to
talk to women what he
say
said something about these that guys
from the red Bill
Community okay he says they're just
ignorant of women they don't talk to
women I think yeah I think a lot of the
guy all right I watch I watch those
channels I keep up with a lot of them
some are good some of them some of them
are bad some are kind of
mixed the problem with a lot of those
channels is that the guys that are
consuming that content are young so
they're they're growing up in in an
online
environment and they're growing up in a
dating scene that I've never
seen and it's supposed to be real
superficial now dating up apps and it's
just like a hookup culture even though
evidently that's supposed to be fading
now people are starting to get off of
those apps that's a terrible way to meet
somebody if you ask me yeah it's it
efficient you can get your hands on a
lot of people but but they're not going
to be the kind of people you want um you
want to meet people in the wild you know
cuz you have you have common interest
and but the problem is a lot of these
young guys don't have any interest in
anything they're just playing video
games they don't ever get get out they
well then hang out with a chick that
likes video games H there's not enough
girls that like video video girls don't
like what are you talking about yeah
they do well they're they're going to be
fighting that's almost like 40% of the
market maybe more okay well if they got
girls in the basement [__] playing
video games getting f and that's what
they need to that's what they need to go
well that's what I'm saying like well
like I said that's what they want I
think well yeah but that's the problem
is that they have unrealistic
expectations what they want is they they
think they're going to find like some
hot model chick that's going to like put
up with their ass they want
Stacy they want Stacy right and [__]
realistically though you need to find a
person that has the same interests as
you the same lifestyle as you like it'll
be a lot easier that way you
know so I I don't really get why well
well no I get why they do it but they're
they're younger dudes and uh the EnV
depending on what state they're coming
out of Florida and the south is still
pretty normal they say some of these
other states you know what I mean
[__] uh the interaction between boys
and girls in high school and even Middle
School is pretty [__] up so uh they're
not really produ and and in general what
I'm hearing is is that the kind of
boys middle school and high school is
producing is not the kind of males that
equivalent women in other words Middle
School and High School women want
anything to do with which that makes
sense because in general that's the way
it was when I was at high school most of
those guys those but the thing is is
that there was still a good success rate
you know there was probably you know 30%
of them dudes are doing real well now I
heard it's a lot less they're going
after the top five
percent and main problem is
obesity obesity and lack of social
skills so so that could get in the way
that can get away of that that really
gets in the way of relationships when
you're young because man relationships
are so superficial at that at those
young ages you know
so a lot of that red pill stuff we call
it red pill stuff a lot of those red
pill videos are targeted towards guys
that I would be considered to be
substandard but how much of it can you
blame on them how much of it can you
blame on society they're not producing
people of quality anymore well the thing
about is I think a lot of that red pill
type media is targeted toward those
types of people to make them feel better
about the fact that they can't um
measure up or they don't want to like
they don't want to make the effort and
it's well I mean the thing about towards
them but it's not defeat is just telling
them that they need to self-improve it
well then that's good but I'm just
saying that there's there's some there's
also a darker side of it too where
they're making a lot of money
telling these dudes well it's not
entirely your fault because women suck
or you know they there's there's kind of
that aspect they're not saying that no I
have seen some of that yeah but that's
not what we're talking about they have
some they have the black pilled guys are
like that all right those ones where oh
[__] that [__] women you know what I
mean but no the red pill guys actually
want by yeah the red pill men going your
own way yeah go your own way bye that's
a different scene I know black
men midtow men going their own ways is
not young guys that's old guys who've
been burned by at least one
divorce they're out of the game they're
checking out so they're 50s 40s
50s that just means that they're going
to be Bachelors that's all that means
that's not the same the black pill guys
are young guys all right who who have
given up they they they're not even
going to pursue dating or women or
relationships so they just said [__] it
which Japan has that they're called uh
vegetarian men I think is what they call
them something like that
vegetarians are where they they're not
interested in meat and they just kind
of stay home and uh I just jerk it to
[__] porn and Anime or something
which not healthy man because that's
sucking um it's not progressing the the
personality that's not character
development that's regression well
there's regressing to an infantile State
there's nothing wrong with porn per se
it's just that if that's all that you
consume it's not that's realistic yeah
that's their relationship Rel that's all
that's the only problem I have with I
don't have a problem with porn in
general obviously yeah but it's not a
substitute for a relationship right yeah
if you're just using it as kind of like
a like a supplement yeah to a
relationship then that's fine but it's
just kind of like if you're using that
instead of then that's probably not good
right and if you're learning all your
[__] from that that's also probably not
good because like I said it's really
unrealistic a lot of it I think they
know that it's just that they don't care
and because they're they're not going to
pursue women which like I said they say
it's too risky okay too risky so uh
you're dealing with the young guys well
don't ask us cuz we don't care yeah well
women do because eventually what what
ends up happening is that there are no
available men they uh get to 31 32 and
they're just no available men the guys
that uh the decent guys are all
married uh the young ones that are good
won't date with her cuz she she's too
old and uh the guys that do want to go
out with that are single are old guys
and they're leftovers all right there's
a reason why they're not married okay um
and you know they're 50 60 and they're
not married and you know 30-year old
woman's not going to be quite that
interested in a 50-some year old guy
especially if he's never been married
there's going to be something why have
you been married now if you're a
millionaire and you look [__] great
you're Jason
Statham that's a different story you
know what I mean you that dude didn't
get married because he had a long string
of [__] hot girlfriends and a [__]
ton of money he didn't have to get
married like I said that's fine that's
fine okay but that's not no one's
getting [__] over in that situation
everyone knows what's going on he knows
on he didn't have to get married as long
as he's not banging 15-year-old I'm fine
with it right it's fine but those guys
are treated very differently than a guy
who is making $25,000 $20,000 a year
he's uh single never been married he's
55 years old has very you know he's not
looking good the thing about it is that
rich people can get away with rich
people get away with all rich people
whether they're men or women can get
away with a lot of [__] that us plees
can't get away with so it's not just
dudes that have to put up
we have to put up with it too so um but
I think women have they're hearing
things secondhand they're not really
hearing it from a lot of times are
hearing it secondhand especially through
especially through women about what
these guys are saying in the red pill
Community or whatever the mgtow computer
they're not really listening to those
guys they're not category they're not
putting them in the proper categories
the mtow guys have been around for
hundreds of [__] years that's not
new guy gets run through and a divorce
loses everything he's not going to be
interested anymore he's
45 okay he's going to say [__] it I'm
going to do my own thing I'm not getting
married again that's been going on
forever so that's not really that new uh
what's new is guys that are in their
[__] late teens or 20s saying [__] it
I'm not I don't even want a girlfriend
well the only thing that's new is that
the only thing that's new is the fact
that like they would just like announce
it like just do it like why why would
anyone care what it is like we don't
care what it is is is there yeah you
don't care that the individual guys in
there all right and and plus another
thing is you have to understand
that you're not a teenage girl okay and
you're not a [__] girl in her 20s who
even back then I didn't
care all right I'm just saying whatever
even back then I didn't care just saying
that another thing is is that you are
nowhere near the average woman nowhere
near if it came along fine if it didn't
nowhere near I know the average woman
you know I know the makeup of but I'm
just saying the average woman is
basically invisible all right to me um
you're nowhere near that so um those
women all miss out on possibly getting
married and having kids because there
are no available
men and then you might say well there's
immigration yeah you bring in these guys
from these other countries but they
don't go out with them either you know
these guys don't really have a pot to
piss any when they first show up and if
they do start doing well then they go
for a higher caliber woman immigration
is not really or they go out with they
instead of Marrying an American woman
they bring another woman from Salvador
wherever they came
from um and just because the guy
immigrated here doesn't mean he's going
to marry your ass you know what I mean
[__] that dude might have good taste
so so a lot of these average women just
kind of get stuck out and then they
become cat mamas
basically and they're not happy about it
like lot of them because a lot of them
wanted to get married wanted to have
kids but that that never came around now
you can do sperm donor donor stuff they
got guys making a lot of money as sperm
donors I didn't realize that but they
have kits where a dude could [__] get
give a sample donate some and then
[__] make a lot of money man you
might be too old but I'm not sure cuz I
looked into egg donation when I was in
my 30s but they don't really want
anybody over 35 though as far as women
go well another thing is is that I
probably would get weeded out because
I'm only 5 six a lot of those [__]
girls are looking for donors that are
like
6'2 because why I don't know why have
short baby when you have a [__] tall
baby all babies are short well you know
what I'm talking about I know I'm just
gazing all right so I don't well I don't
think they give you as much money as for
that as they do for women's eggs because
like obviously it's a lot more they're
not doing it through companies they're
doing it through social media yeah oh
you would do you want to desp
vation
dude just sends the sample she pays him
directly yeah it's only like a hundred
bucks I could probably think of like
some they got doing that yeah okay they
would want like a little Tom run around
yeah and and you never can't tell who
it's like lesbian couples well that's
what I'm saying like you know or it's
like uh like I said I we probably know
some people that would that would pay
for your sperm random black chicks that
want lightskinned babies they're doing
that too uh [__] Sal look into it you
can make some money like that yeah but
you
know yeah she pays dude 50 bucks to send
it to him well like I said there's nodle
there's no
middleman if you donate eggs it's a lot
it's a lot harder well it's a lot more
complicated process they have to do this
they got one dude they have to give you
all these drugs to like um you know
manufacture more eggs and then they have
to like Harvest them and it's this whole
no this dud
just got to jerk it it just has to Jer
takes like 10 minutes yeah into [__]
plastic bag I think and he puts it in
[__] yeah dry ice and [__] sends
her a syringe and everything here have a
turkey base here yeah here's a turkey
base so uh and and wham bam it's done
but they had one dude they were
interviewing him and I think he said he
sold over 300 samples and as far as he
knows that he he could be
like like
[Laughter]
that he has like kids all over that he
doesn't know about but the thing is is
that I have to pay for a single one well
here's the [__] here's the [__] thing
right he didn't really charge any money
it was just a [__] donation and she
had to cover the [__] shipping yeah
well I mean I've heard of um people
doing it like for friends and stuff yeah
like I said like for lesbian couples or
things like that it's like you know they
have a male friend that they really like
and they you know they're like hey can
you donate sperm so we can have a baby
and stuff like that it's like that's
fairly common I think but you know cuz
you know that person and you know it's
like yeah it'd be cool if we had a kid
that had that those attributes you know
we probably know some people like that
but like you said it's much easier for a
dude to like donate stuff because it
takes like 5 10 minutes oh he's talking
about that Oliver Reed program that we
played the priest but we saw that one
that was a go Bryce says um I'm kind of
behind but he says talking to bad dun
saying that he's like um asexual now
yeah uh you should try having women as
friends I got a lot of female friends
that I would never bang having girls as
friends is good to get familiar with
them that's how you develop your
own I don't I don't know what that last
word is
Riz yeah but yeah I think that's like I
said I think that was one of the things
too that
first um attracted me to Tom like I said
other than like he was a snappy dresser
and he could dance which like I said is
very rare but um the fact that he did
have a lot of female friends and like I
said a lot most of those like 95% of his
female friends he had never slept with
so he just and they were hot and like a
lot of them were hot so I liked that I
like that he just liked them as people
and he hung out with them and like
talked to them about whatever like some
of them were into motorcycles or some of
them were into the same [__] as him you
know what I mean so it's like they would
just talk about that and I was just like
I thought that was kind of cool because
a lot of dudes will not do that a lot of
dudes kind of feel like well I'll make
friends with a chick there it it's
always um a lot of dudes see befriending
women as like goal oriented I feel like
um you know it's like oh maybe I'll you
know I'll I'll get to [__] her at the
end you know what I mean um and Tom is
not like that you know what I mean he's
just kind of like oh this is like a cool
person so I mean he is very just like
yeah I'm going to [__] this person but
he's not like that like about a lot of
people he's just like ah they're just a
cool person you know what I mean like I
like the same [__] that they like so
they just he just talks to him about
that and
that's a little bit unusual at least in
my experience so I think that was kind
of one of the things
that um that kind of stood out Oracle
said anybody who gets on Jenny's nerves
is probably not a good person that is
probably true um and I'm not saying that
I'm a super patient person because I'm
not I'm super impatient got that from my
dad
but I'm um I'm willing to give uh people
the benefit of the doubt I'm not going
to [__] with you unless you are it's
unless it's real
egregious or unless it's been going a
long time like I said with that one girl
and I just got sick of it but that had
been like 18 months at least right what
that when that whole [__] with that
[__] went on when oh yeah I mean that
had been going on that wasn't just that
one night that had been going on for
like a year and a half that was serial
behavior and I was just kind of like man
I am so [__] sick of this [__] that
chick was fighting for me man she wanted
the D bad yeah bad well she saw
it and you did you went home with her
that one night yeah she saw it she saw
it but I didn't give it to
her being have a con yeah that was the
whole thing yeah he called me the next
day and told me about it yeah yeah yeah
cuz I was mad I was like you [__]
left me at the bar you [__] I had by
the time all that [__] was going down
with her I was like man this shick's too
[__] goofy man this chick's Scoopy i
i a I tried to tell you I was like I was
like if I do this I'll never get rid of
this chick and [__] I was I was kind
well see that's kind of what I told i'
never get rid of this that's kind of
what I told you and it's just like the
fact that you went home with her like
you didn't have you didn't have sex with
her I got tricked though kind of in that
when I was drunk and I didn't realize
when I got in the car with I didn't
realize she was taking me to her place
right I thought we were just going to
drive around block a couple times and
then come back you still had a drink in
your hand yeah I got in a car with a
drink it's [__] Florida man yeah
[__] Florida yeah I had to drink in
the [__] car and open I driving
around in her car she was I was just I
was right across the street I was at a
bar yeah across the street having a
drink with my friend Mike that's right
so you left so I thought yeah but I told
you I texted you yeah but I and said I'm
just going to have a drink with Mike we
weren't going out anymore at that point
yeah yeah for some and then I'll be back
I was drinking all my [__] was at your
house I was I was drinking and at the
time I was like yeah she she' be going
home with that guy no I wasn't planning
on it but I ended up having to because I
didn't have a ride home and all my all
my work clothes I had to go to work the
next day and all my work clothes were at
your house yeah yeah I know it was so I
had to wear the same [__] to work I
forgot yeah listen that I I wasn't aware
of any of that when I was drunk I wasn't
thinking about it just telling you
that's what happened it was not mean
spirited why she sold this [__] against
it was not mean-spirited but that's why
I wasn't thinking about it really that's
why I was upset though like I just
pardon you didn't seemed to understand
why I was upset that's why I was upset I
was partying man I for I didn't I didn't
realize it was up
mhm well I was used to doing that kind
of stuff anyway yeah but you know you
know with other female friends and [__]
that would happen all the time but you
did drive me there and all my [__] was
at your house all my work clothes yeah
you with that dude for the next morning
in my thinking you were with that dude
he had it he had it under control no I
texted you I'm having one drink across
the street I didn't see no you texted me
back okay all right see and then you
said I'm going home with what's her name
and I was just like all my shit's at
your house and then you just bye you
didn't you didn't text me back I didn't
see that
probably me yeah this [__] happens man
so then I said to Mike I was just kind
of like um can I stay at your house yeah
which you all worked I wasn't planing
like you're homeless or
anything well if he hadn't been there
I'd probably had to sleep in my car
no or sleep on the street had he had he
not been there then I wouldn't have left
with what's her name probably no you
probably still would no because you'd
have been around you'd have been around
to make sure that the [__] didn't happen
I just look we're going over see this is
the thing audience she loves to bring
this [__] up you were not my girlfriend
at that
time we were just buddies oh I know that
you were seeing that other guy when you
when you left under under under the
influence of alcohol when you I was like
yeah she'll be all right she'll be good
she's she's hooked up with that guy and
then [__] she's going come on come on
come on let's go and the other one I'm
like okay then I guess I'll just chill
with this one and then you know I
thought we were just going to ride
around a block but then when she started
heading towards her house I i' [__] I
text you I said I'm going home with
her it wasn't you know mean or anything
it wasn't being mean I was just telling
you where I was going I forgot all about
your stuff being at my house yeah well
that was [__]
loaded yeah I know you forgot yeah I was
loaded I forgot about forgot man I was
so
upset never see the phone never been
left anywhere like that and then and
then I didn't see look at see how she
rubs it in she I never been left
anywhere man you were you were in the
company of a dude that could take care
of you you were taken care of it didn't
end your life yeah okay it was it was a
minor inconvenience but I I I forgot
about it I was [__] loaded you
know she's just trying to get dick she's
just trying to run in and get dick
I'm going to get some sympathy dick
tonight I can get a dick anytime I want
what are you talking about I don't need
sympathy I'll give you a dick even when
you don't want it Tammy said that makes
it worse Jenny was supposed to be your
friend and you abandoned her yeah I
thought she went have to go get late
that too I thought she was on forget
later no I told you that I was coming
back but I didn't see any of that man
[__] I was partying and [__] I just I
just getting text yeah she texting like
I said y know how I do man at that point
me and him hadn't been a thing for a
while I'm a man I don't [__] analyze
it like that we just went over and have
a drink and I was just like oh I'll be
back in a minute like it was just it was
literally across the street it was at
Place Lizzie McGuire I'm a man I I'm a
man I'm I'm used to reading in between
the lines I figured okay she's going to
go and [__] that dude no that would
there were no lines to read between I
was telling you exactly what was happen
because that's what the average woman
that I was used to would have been doing
right but that wasn't what I was doing
yeah so like gets real wrapped up on
this well yeah holding holding me to
high standards when I was that was an
ERA in where I didn't really know her as
well as I know her now and uh I was used
to women doing that I tell you exactly
so what I'm doing and where I'm going
yeah why wouldn't I so did all the other
ones that was [__] up at the same
time they all say that they all say so I
was I had I guess you could say I had a
very um um
I don't want to say I had trust issues
it's just that I didn't believe that
women tell me no because I was used to
being lied to but I didn't hold it I I
didn't have a garage I just I just you
know I was came from a culture where
women chose themselves over everybody
else they did what they wanted to do uh
you could take them to a club and they
could leave with another dude that
happened several times all right but you
don't get hard-hearted about it you're
like all right yeah [__] her I'll just
[__] somebody else all right she found
somebody else better than me whatever
you know it just I was Jenny doesn't
have the body count that I have you know
right and well like I said I was very
battle hardened and I will not apologize
for not being like that I was Battle
hardened so I was reading from a
different book a different Playbook and
I was reading it from a different eyes I
was like okay she's getting back with
her ex now that's the way I saw that she
get back just because you said I I Haden
seen him in a while but see here's the
deal that's not what I told you I was
used to being lied too I expected but I
don't really know what else I can tell
you I just I told you exactly what was
going to happen yeah I said we went over
here to have one beer I hadn't seen him
in a while he's a cool guy yeah and it's
like you know we hadn't been a thing for
a while but I was just like oh okay I'll
come have a beer with you I said I'll be
right back we're just going to have a
beer and I'll come right back the way
all my shit's at your house yeah my
interpretation of that in those days was
I'm hooking back up with my ex I'm gonna
[__] him tonight I'll probably see you
tomorrow that's what that meant to me n
I didn't even [__] him that night I
didn't I figured you probably would nope
I didn't
okay I slept at his house I slept in his
bed but I you were in custody of your
ex-boyfriend we did not have sex and I
wasn't pissed I wasn't pissed cuz I was
mad I was upset I was but I wasn't
pissed at you I was really upset I was
so I couldn't get into it because I was
like we didn't even try yeah I wasn't he
he knew that he was just I was just kind
of like can I just sleep at your house
because I don't have anywhere to go and
he's like yeah okay how long ago was
this
um I don't know this was about four 15
years 2010 20 2010 21 you realiz you
still been out of shape over something
15 years ago it was just one
night yeah you're still milk it made mad
you're still trying to milk this yeah
that's the only thing I did to you
[__] over the 15 years that still
makes you mad with that no you've done
other things okay you want to bring that
up too no for everybody to see you've
done other things I'm thinking of one
thing in particular but um there's other
things too okay yeah yeah well I I do
[__] yeah I do [__]
some but like I said if I tell you
something and you know this now I guess
but it's like if I tell you something
that's exactly what I mean I'm not
playing games I'm not doing anything
like I just don't do that yeah Bryce is
agree with me but yeah because I came
from that background I didn't really
believe what women said because I was
used to them lying to me so that's just
that was my interpretation I thought it
was just political speak you know I'll
be back in a minute now do means you're
not coming back no that's exactly what I
meant yeah to the average girl hey I'm
hanging out with my ex I'll be back in a
minute means I'm hooking back up with my
ex tonight I'll see you tomorrow that's
what that means right I get it but
that's not what I me yeah that's what I
thought was happening that's not what I
meant so then I got back there and you
were gone and I was just kind of like
well I'm [__] especially with all that
damn alcohol that we were drinking at
the time yeah okay so that's just my
that was my interpretation of what it
was cuz I'm definitely not one of these
simpy [__] to be sitting here
she never came back of course you she
didn't come back but I would have yeah
but you were how would I know how would
I know that I wouldn't know that the
average woman the average woman would
never come back I would have come back
yeah I don't I didn't know you I don't
do that kind of [__] I didn't really
know you back then you know I don't do
that kind of [__] to people that's
shitty most people that's the so funny
thing is that you defending all these
[__] fictional women and [__] most
women would just like [__] that
dude well I don't know like I said I can
only speak for myself you know most
women are about most women are about
themselves I don't I don't do that kind
of crap I don't do shitty stuff to
people like that most women are about
themselves most most if I drive somebody
to the club I'm going to take care of
them Bry make sure they get home Bryce
you and I
know the average
woman is working for herself she's an
independent
contractor well everyone
is they see dudes as dirt and kind of
[__]
interchangeable I don't think that's the
case yeah most of them do I don't think
that's the case I think so I think so
well I think so because you you can see
it in their
behavior hypergamy part of it uh and
then another thing is is that the
average dude really ain't [__] you know
so they're kind of and and I'm I'm as a
guy I'm going to say that the average
dude a't [__] the average woman ain't
[__] either really but she might be a
little bit better than the average guy
um and in certain
ways uh because of the guy the male
mating strategy the guy is a little bit
less trustworthy on the average than the
average female
so I'm not blaming women but you see the
thing is is that modern cultur is really
[__] really heavily leading into the
concept of virtue of who's right and
who's wrong wrong I don't really have
those Concepts I don't care who's right
or wrong I only care about what
happens I don't see myself as a virtuous
person not by condition not by
traditional standards and I would never
want to be virtuous by traditional
conventional standards because when you
look at what they're touting as virtue I
just see that
as being a sap or a sucker you know the
so no that's not for
me it's kind of like in religious virtue
it's [__] most of it you know
artificial the average person today
average secular person who's [__]
steeped
in social media their virtue has been
dictated to them by
corporations about how a good person
should be and that's listening to
corporations that's the last people you
want to listen to that's worse than
listening to a country or a nation at
least with a nation there's some kind of
a
[__] concept of ethnicity or an
ethnic group that's trying to hold
together it's like a big big family or
something with corporations that no it's
just they just try to get you to believe
things that make them money they want
you to believe things that make you weak
so they can become stronger than you
everything's about
power so I don't
know
I don't care that I'm bad I don't care
that other people think that I'm
bad you just got to be kind of
indifferent to it I believe in what I do
I don't care what other people think
about it that's what I'm trying to say
most people think that I'm bad I
think but if I'm bad it's because you
all made me bad oh you're blaming
everyone else now yeah yeah I'm a
product of my environment and
jeans
well then other people are too yeah they
are they are that's why I don't like
them okay whatever it's only exceptional
people you
know if you become my friend in real
life and we're we're talking then you
can I I'll Trust you you can trust
me uh but like I said you know what I
mean [__] uh men and women have
different styles and they have different
uh uh [__] priorities and different
limitations so it's going to look
different
like Jen said I don't I'm not anti-woman
I got I got I actually trust women more
than
men I had more female friends than guy
friends in recent years you probably do
actually now that I'm thinking about it
I don't know maybe it's probably 50/50
well I don't know no more female friends
yeah
probably you have you have a lot of
friends of both sexes yeah but it's it's
mostly females yeah and
um but I kind of vetted them you I who
they are and I'm not trying to have
relationships with them to where you
know it's like our relationship I'm not
trying to sleep with them or get married
to them or anything like
that but I know him well and matter of
fact the one that I've known here the
longest is with would would be J um um
Laura Laura Ross yeah yeah we have the
same last name but we're not directly
related not related yet and
Laura I guess I was in my late 30s when
I met Laura I've known her longer than
I've known you yeah I was about 38 when
I met her she's [__] awesome I love
her and she was probably only about 22
when at that time yeah she's younger
she's significantly younger than we when
and Laura's probably one of the best
looking women in Orlando oh my God she
is [__] beautiful yeah all right and
she's awesome yeah and she's super sweet
super good person I'll show you a
picture in a minute um but when I met
Laura Laura had a boyfriend but we
became friends so I never really saw her
as available when when I first met her
you know and she was younger than me and
she was getting her [__] together but we
hung out we talked a lot she'd come you
know hang out with me at Starbucks and
stuff and I
just always liked her but I never really
kind of had that [__] mindset where I
was going to like scope on her like I'm
gonna get this I never looked at her
that way because she treated me well so
I just treated her well like as
individuals you know yeah which like I
said more dudes should do that actually
yeah now here's the
thing earlier on I said the average
woman is kind of bad but so is the
average guy the average guy is kind of
worse than the average woman yeah I
would say that all right so that's so
we're getting back to truth now you know
what I
mean Laura was
a very beautiful but she was a good
person which is rare a lot of women who
look really good and become kind of
predatory they're not good to dudes they
just kind of use them them
up uh they they use their looks against
guys to get what they want not this one
this one she was special just special I
mean she is like ridiculous beautiful
ridiculous yeah here I'll show you guys
a
picture I've had that though like when I
first started going out with this one
guy he told me which and he was much
younger than I was but he said you know
you're not like most girls that look
like you yeah you told you yeah and said
you mean that I'm not a [__] yeah and
he's like yeah that's what I that's what
I meant cuz I'm not a [__] but you know
what I mean well I can be but but yeah I
I do kind of I don't think that's true
though because I know a lot of really
really beautiful women that are not
[__] that are like that are super
nice well a lot of these guys like you
know like like Bryce was saying some of
these blackpilled guys you know what I
mean that [__] have just given up and
[__] those are the same kind of dudes
and some of the red pill guys they're
the same kind of dudes that would see
her see Laura and think that oh well
[__] you got to be a millionaire and you
got to look a certain way you know I
mean you got to be a [__] you know a
supermodel type guy and [__] Jack
with sixpack no the dude she's with he's
kind of an average guy uh he's awesome
though yeah he's the same birthday as me
he's a nice guy and he he's not swimming
in money or anything they go to all the
horror conventions and they do amazing
cosplay yeah amazing
yeah and I love that I love that they
they're like into the same kind of [__]
so they will do these like really
elaborate costumes and [__] like that
she has like a different costume for
every night of the of the thing that's
what Laura looked like when I met her
when I met her she looked like that
she's probably about 22 maybe 21 yeah
she's probably in her 30s now but
yeah so that's another thing don't get
the impression that because I kind of
this is funny too I was I think I said
this to you the other day our friend
ammani who is a um club promoter in this
area she told us she wanted to approach
us because she was um promoting some
shows in Orlando she mostly does she
does goth bands but she mostly does
black metal and so she wanted to
approach us to help her promote some
shows in the area and she knew that we
were you know kind of knew everybody in
the scene and stuff so she wanted to
come talk to us but she told us later
after she met us that she was afraid to
come talk to us at first because we
looked
really [__] yeah and that we looked
really intimidating she's like you guys
are over there at iar and you're in the
corner and you're over there smoking
your [__] cigarettes cuz we both
smoked back then and um she's like and
you just look like complete
[__] like and she's like and I was
afraid to come over talk to you because
I thought you would just be like [__]
off [__] or whatever but we're totally
not like that we're really nice and it's
just like it's funny that people think
that just from like looking like I can
see how they would look at us from
across the bar if you don't know us
maybe we look scary from if you don't
know us but we're totally not we're
totally not trying to get a picture of
Laura looks about like that
now I don't know yeah she she still
looks like that she is seriously one of
the sweetest people I have ever met
maybe the sweetest person I've ever met
super sweet and
uh just she's awesome like her boyfriend
is awesome too now these are he is also
awesome they're super nice these are the
three best looking women in
Orlando there's Jen our friend Jen Laura
and
Jenny remember that poster I made that
poster yeah Jenny made that poster for
one ran took
that yeah that was how long ago was that
old house yeah that was about 5 years
ago probably about 5 years ago yeah he
came over our house and took that
picture like all of us were over there
having some drinks and he took a bunch
of pictures of us and I used him in a
bunch of stuff yeah I think I think I uh
this is another poster that Jen made of
Jen our friend Jen and Laura yeah yeah
yeah that was like when they did like a
carnival thing yeah yeah I remember that
open my wor
yeah but so yeah so that's another thing
you can't just because I do kind of feel
like some types of dudes have a
perception that oh if a if a girl is
really like good-look that she must be
like super [__] or a gold digger or
something like that and that is
absolutely not the case a lot of the
times yeah but uh I can think of I know
a lot of women yeah that are like super
hot women that are not like that
so like I said you can't just you can't
judge you can't judge they're talking
about Oliver Reed movies yeah they're
talking about the Devils we actually
reviewed that not too long ago yeah
that's the one I was I told you he
mentioned that I really like the devil
that was the one where the chick the
chick was in the NY in love with him and
lying yeah it's like based on a tree
story kind of yeah kind of yeah [__]
Bryce said yeah she's beautiful yeah
she's 30 she's in her late 30s now I
think is she or mid-30s mid late 30s I
can't remember how old she is and she
still looks just like that yeah she
hasn't changed uh and like I said her
and her boyfriend do amazing cosplay
yeah at this past was it Spooky Empire
her um them two and like a friend of
theirs did the um who were the the
villains from Superman that were in the
in the Square yeah yeah they were in The
Phantom Zone The Phantom Zone pH they
did The Phantom Zone they had like the
whole Phan and they were all dressed up
like those characters and they were like
like inside this [__] square it was
awesome it was so awesome they were a
fan and it kind of the photo went kind
of viral but yeah that's Laura and
that's her boyfriend Adam and I don't
remember who the other guy was but yeah
they did like a whole [__] cosplay of
that and they they like go all out for
all the horror conventions and sci-fi
conventions and stuff and they come up
with like some great [__] outfits
every time I see their [__] I'm just got
like oh man how' they [__] think of
that because they'll do like really
obscure [__] it's awesome all right I
gotta pee again
yeah Sebastian says well I saw the
devils in my 20s but I always preferred
Target bring out the masculinity the
toxic masculinity brings out the
masculinity I I don't know what Target
is don't about the the [__] store
Target Jason says I kind of sound like
an insult no I'm not [__] an Insel
this is the [__] thing I think I I
think I I said this earlier in the show
there's no such thing as an
NSL
the guys that call themselves in cells
or other people call them in they're not
involuntary involuntarily sell it
they're voluntarily celibate they've
done they've voluntarily done all the
things you have to do to remain
celibate there's a lot of [__]
up things happening in uh modern culture
you know [__] happening with social
media and the Internet it's kind of it's
kind of a
misnomer the average inel is
[__] he's not he's he he's being
salel it on purpose yeah I mean he's
going out of his way to become even that
[__] dude that Elliot
Rogers that goofy
[__] I watched his
videos wasn't a badl looking guy just
[__] weird as [__] he was doing [__]
that would drive women away and he was
doing that [__] kind of on purpose uh
you he was putting effort into that
style into that strategy and that is not
the strategy you want but the thing is
is that I think Elliot
Rogers we talked about it before I kind
of psychoanalyzed him and analyzed what
I could feel from him using all of my
[__] psychic
powers that dude wasn't normal I think
uh he had some kind clearly not he had
some kind of mental problem I don't know
if it was like severe autism or not
severe cuz my cousin Wesley he had
severe autism but it doesn't look like
that severe autism when you're
especially and he was deaf at the same
time severe autism to him was tracking
down every [__] knole on every piece
of [__] wood he could find putting
numbers and cataloging them okay and
[__] he could memorize [__] Thomas
map books [__] from front to back he
was like a walking [__] GPS this is
long before GPS this back back the 70s
you could give him two points on the
[__] map in anywhere in the United
States he could tell you exactly how how
many miles away that was and then he
could give you the roots what [__]
what what roads you had to take to get
there but uh
anyway U now Elliot Rogers wasn't a
normal
inel Nells are dude just can't get
laid really that's all it is but there's
a lot of dudes that are like that they
can't get laid dudes with
[__] bad physical health they're not
going to be able to get laid to just you
know he my guy might have leprosy you
know maybe get laid with a
leper or a dude just [__] just
doesn't have the physical health to
attract women or he doesn't have the
mental health to attract
women so I guess you say that's an in
Cel but that's not a normal dude so
they're in a different you know somebody
who's horribly disfigured in some way
well so yeah some of that is like way
outside of their control out of control
right right it's not like they can fix
it right but a lot of these guys who are
online saying they're incels they could
be fixed sure there's nothing really
inherently wrong with them no I imagine
there probably
isn't I remember seeing the first of the
[__] incels this is [__] back in
the early Wild West the internet back I
might need another drink for this here
get me a little bit too okay how much
you want just a little bit of ioda and
and some and a little bit more put your
fingers thing and some ice okay make her
[__] Bart me a drink
[__] oh now she's coming back with a
drink I don't say that to you I know I
just [__] make a drink I just make a
drink
anyway yeah go make me a
sandwich anyway uh
the thing
with the thing I remember I was saying
that back in the old internet back in
the back in the
90s we used to get on these damn [__]
thread uh what do they call them
discussion groups they were like these
big threads I mean I imagine some of you
guys from are old enough to remember
those discussion
boards and some of them were you know
they be about guns or motorcycles or
whatever and you get to know all those
dudes this is before Facebook you start
to get to know them they start posting
pictures and then these dudes start
these epic fights with each other poed
pictures and some of these dudes were
just so [__] dorky
man they're literally the living in
their mom's basement kind of guys uh
overweight
depressed [__] don't know how to
dress they didn't do they kind of
socially failed in high school
so they never really learned the skills
or they never learned the never learned
the social skills they never got any
confidence so they just kind of [__]
got into this like a death spiral a
social death
spiral nowadays they call those guys in
sales that they're involuntarily
celibate but I don't think that's a good
I don't think that's a good uh way to
look at it
it's oh man that's a lot
you're welcome thanks that's like man
now I got to piss all this
out well that's true of any liquid [__]
how much of that is
vodka like that much oh so it's pretty
weak it's mostly ice okay to be honest
with you don't get
excited okay man you go make me a
sandwich [__] I heard that I
talking about I cook every [__] day
you do yeah I cook every [__] day I
bring me I ask stop bringing the meals
up here I call her and make her come
down the stairs and get it I'll leave
the [__] on the stairs on the
steps cuz well cuz sometimes I can't
hear you cuz sometimes I'm up here
working or she's like what and then she
go oh cuz she knows it's lunch time you
know like I said oh I'm usually working
on [__] and like sometimes I have videos
going like research videos going on in
the background and [__] like that I'm
like what I made green salsa today cuz
uh I picked all the [__] tomatillos
tomatillos I got the little [__]
Mexican tomatillos growing out there
with Le lemon tree put lime juice in it
tomatillos [__] roasted them along
with tomatoes got all kind of [__]
growing back there some chili peppers
jalapan Peppers roasted them onion
roasted it garlic roasted it and then
blended it all in a damn jar and then
chilled it made green salsa [__] was
awesome that's what I gave you on that
little um it was it was like a u what do
you call it like a quesadilla kind of
yeah quesadilla Hamburg hamburger and
cheese cheese quesadilla just lift it up
real quick and earlier for lunch we had
butter chicken that you made that butter
chick butter chicken I still have two
servings left maybe
three your butter chicken is one of the
best things that you make yes it I agree
yeah that's good that's good butter
chicken I mean all the [__] you make is
good but I think the butter chicken is
probably your favorite although you know
what we haven't had a while papash
haven't made that in a while also
haven't made boki oh you haven't made
boki in a while yeah
yeah I used to like it used to make boki
out of pork pork tender line which
supposed to be beef it's supposed to be
beef but you know whatever CL enough
pork T beef pears yeah um onions onions
yeah yeah roasted it well you marinate
it and then roast it slice it thin and
roast it Oracle said she was going to
crash good seeing everybody a Bryce
laughing go make me a sand yeah I pulled
a sandwich line that's classic line
classic as in like old yeah yeah yeah
Oracle says Tom that uh oo pork recipe
from your cookbook has become our
regular Sunday dinner okay yeah yeah
thank you oo Pork yeah it's good yeah
that's some good [__]
yep Danny rolling said is there any
chance that we would review the 1996
film edville The Dollhouse which was
surprisingly decent you know what I've
never seen that and I keep seeing it
like pop up on stuff and I'm just kind
of
like other than I watched maybe the
first three Amityville movies oh and the
weird one about the clock cuz that was
on RI tracks yeah but I don't think I've
seen any of the other how many movie
amville movies are there now 19 yeah I
want to say it's 19 I'm not really sure
Bryce is agreeing with me that those
guys are not incels it's a mixture of
like hatred and weird [__] that they
have I well like I said I think a lot of
it if they just got their [__]
together um and stop
focusing yeah well like I said I think
the problem is a lot of dudes see women
as like a goal it's like goal oriented
like don't come at [__] like that well
that is one of their goals is they want
to get a girlfriend because they never
had one so that makes it worse yeah the
the the uh [__] and [__] doesn't happen
naturalistically like where you just got
to sit around and it happens it's not
like that either you got
self-development and [__] going on
adventures and doing [__] leads to this
stuff but it also leads to car character
building and you got to build character
build your body build your mind your
soul your spirit learn to make friends
with people learn what enemies are it's
I'm a holistic type [__] I I I
like the the dark side and the light
there's another t-shirt Tom is a
holistic [__] there's only
certain things that you're going to
learn there's certain things you can
only learn by walking a dark path okay
and uh some of it is [__] like okay I
know what this is I'm not going to go
any further down this this is a bad path
but it's still you can come back from
pretty much anything uh now serial
murder no okay now that's a different
case you [__] you know what I mean
[__] uh [__] like that yeah pretty
much forever but you know reasonable
stuff or you know actually some of the
[__] I did wasn't reasonable uh crazy
[__] but but like I said but people have
done worse [__] than you've done yeah
right yeah you know what I mean yeah not
everybody but a lot of people have done
wor [__] done and have come back from it
so yeah
so but the
uh they're celibate because of what they
have volunte doing now
this some wisdom that was said in one of
the [__] Star Wars movies i' like to
say it one time it comes from Buddhism
really
or it's it's not really said in the same
way Obi W Kenobi tells [__] Anakin
Skywalker he says stop focusing on the
negative because reality becomes
whatever you focus on that's absolutely
true if you [__] keep looking for
problems you're going to see problems if
you keep looking for people not liking
you that's what you're going to create
other people call it manifestation no it
is what you focus on if you keep
thinking women are going to [__] you
over then you'll never be in a situation
where you're going to be happy where
women are going to be nice you're going
be defending it and you're always going
to be defensive and women are going to
sense that and they're going to react to
you accordingly yep they can sense the
negativity in you it's not always it's
not always them sometimes it's
youself right sometimes and like not
always but a lot of times you're you're
sending out vibes that are making people
react negatively to you and then later
on [__] Yoda says that [__] uh one
of the big things is [__] to not go
down the dark path is learning to learn
how to let go what you fear to lose the
most so yeah you might get involved with
this girl you might get your heart
broken you might lose so what so what
you just do it again and don't learn
don't learn from your mistakes had I
learned from my mistakes I never would
have been a serial
monogamist I said oh [__] I got [__]
over that's it I'm through I'm done just
like these black you just got [__]
know get back on the [__] horse man
yeah that's what they tell you talking
about because it's going to be kind of a
numbers
game I mean I didn't do that and the
thing is I'm married fairly young yeah
um you know and I was married for a long
time so I didn't really get back into
the dating scene or whatever until I was
in my late 30s yeah and you know I kind
of I didn't really think about it like
that I'm just like hey I'm free now I'm
just going to like have some fun for a
little while but then you know I met you
and that whole thing like developed but
yeah I didn't
really try to force it really I don't
feel like uh maybe I did I'm not really
sure
no remember that time Sonia was like
remember we were hanging out with Sonia
too and Sonia was hanging out even
before you know me and you were thing
where and F Sonia was like she's trying
to go out with you but don't go out with
her cuz she just broke up with that dude
give her some time you know what I mean
let her go play the field [__] you
know I did I didn't go crazy but yeah I
did do a little bit so cuz I never got a
chance to so you know I I agreed with
her I was like yeah that's what she
needs that was one of the reasons why we
were just kind of like we were friends
but we were like on again which I get it
cuz I was kind of on you needed to
[__] go be free for a while right
which actually that was like a lot of
weight off me cuz we could be friends I
didn't have to take you seriously like
like oh I got to go out with this girl
is you know what I mean it was like no
let her chill out and decompress you
were married what 13 15 years 14 years
14 years you needed to decompress and I
never cheated on that dude never yeah so
it's just kind of like so all that time
you needed to get some more experience
and get get a couple more guys
underneath your belt so you could see
what was out there yeah cuz you your
your judgment of what was available was
not ready yet well I hadn't really been
out and about cuz I had been looking you
know what I mean so it's just kind of
like cuz that wasn't really my thing she
might think I was [__] but I was
actually cognizant of what was going on
no I knew what was going on I knew what
was going on I mean you're you are kind
of an [__] but I knew what was going
on regardless yeah I know what I was
doing I knew what you were doing yeah
like I got it it was kind of frustrating
but
I got it I knew where you were coming
from yeah you know I didn't go anywhere
I know you didn't yeah you didn't go
anywhere NOP you not going anywhere just
kind of like added to it like okay I
guess I guess we are a thing yeah which
is kind of hilarious yeah I guess that's
not usually the way [__]
happens but right that's the thing [__]
doesn't usually last though right well
another thing is is that we were both
divorced from other people so we knew
the deal it's not the same relationships
in your [__] 20s like okay here's
another thing Bryce you talking about
those red pill guys their arguments and
their worries are always coming
from uh the age group of guys in their
20s man you're you're you're thinking in
your requirements there during that
period are not realistic from the point
of view of somebody in their 40s or 50s
yeah once you get old like us once you
get older those priorities they don't
matter the they're worried about doesn't
really matter as much but the reason why
they're worried about this [__] is
because they're thinking about wanting
to date these girls that they want to
marry and have kids with when really you
should a guy should be trying to have
kids marri getting married and having
kids in his 20s that way he can get it
over
with and by the time the kids are grown
he's still young enough to do something
for him you know so I can understand
that but they're
looking the they're seeing things from
the point of view of the first marriage
when you're young trying to start a
family family so a lot of that advice
works for
that if you're in your 40s and
above on a second marriage your
priorities and what you want out of life
are a lot different yeah it's completely
different because you're not Young
starting a family and Sh you're over
that you already got either you did it
or you didn't I didn't because I didn't
want to so so it's not they're not in
the same situation I'm in so I'm not
always sometimes I'll laugh I'll chuckle
at what they're talking her body counter
is too high and like her body count is
too high at four [__] you talking about
you know holy crap that's like half of
mine and mine is super low like [__] you
talking about you know
now now there's some weird extreme
[__] some girl in her 20s maybe she's
been with 50 or 60 dudes and you like
yeah she's she's might have some
problems with monogamy well that's kind
of excessive sure but but what would
happen if this one girl she has the
[__] her body count is 500 at 25
you're like 500 yeah yeah what happens
if she got captured by some dudes in
another country was forced to work in a
brel for a couple years you don't know
like what everyone situation say well
you not going to trust that girl that
girl may want nothing to do with that
kind of Life yeah she got forced into it
yeah you know what I mean and then like
I said that's why you can't judge you
don't know what that individual
situation is so an extreme situation
like that is not the same situation that
these red pill dudes are talking about
you'd have to ask yourself okay well I
am into this chick yeah she got forced
into that by some [__] Bandits or
something down in Mexico [__] couple
you know 10 years ago but she's I like
her you know what I mean fing you're GNA
have and it wasn't her fault you know
right you if you if you like her then go
for it if you think she's not [__] up
you know which I mean you're going to be
kind of [__] up from that yeah yeah
there's risks there the thing is is that
a woman could even come back from that
you know well you can come back from
anything depending yeah but you know you
just got to like [__] be patient man
cuz that's some that's horrific if that
had [__] happen you know what I mean
it happens I know it does it's a Central
American F thing like I said that kills
me like people really think a body can
of four is
excess
well that that [__] you know I mean
you're looking at the dude cuz I'm
sitting there I'm I'm counting I'm just
kind of like you got to consider the
source I think mine is like twice that
yeah the dude the dude that said that
and you they were all longterm and
mine's like low cuz like I said I was
married for 14 years and I didn't cheat
from my point of view she was a virgin
right that's super low
yeah that's lower than me and I'm pretty
low
yeah mine's like what is my like I but
you know the dude the dude that's going
to say say that for you know he's a dude
probably a virgin himself and he's
[__] 17 or 18 you know so you never
can't tell what it ISD thing to say just
you look at read those comments those
comment sections on those videos you
don't know who's talking you know
right it might be it might be a 17-year-
old virgin probably it probably is to be
honest with you it's just I don't know
it just seems like a
weird it seems like a weird thing to
obsess about to me I'm just saying it's
it's a weird thing to obsess
about like I said you don't even know
what your body count
is you didn't keep count I I don't think
it's in the triple
digits although it wouldn't surprise me
if but like I said you were single for a
long time yeah and you're 54 yeah so
it's not the body count thing doesn't
matter that much when you're old right I
just can't believe I never got any STDs
never got any STD well you were very
lucky in that R yeah well they were all
good women yeah pretty much yeah it's
not like you were kind of yeah and you
know in Korea there were some pros
there they were good girls uh but you
know they were professionals but it was
all condoms and stuff well yeah and they
always they they kind of had your back
and they had they were all military
clients that she's dealing with and
she's being in those days they had to go
through medical checkups and [__] they
had licenses and [__] that's what I mean
so it's just kind of like it wasn't like
you were like picking up street hookers
or anything and they weren't really
screwing the public it was kind of like
a military back brothel basically but it
was all kind of a lot of people don't
know
that during that
era the Korean government kind of gave
those girls a bunch of training and they
had these
programs and they kind of told them it
was their patriotic duty to to do this
if they getting into the business
because it was getting money out of the
U out of the American pockets and
getting it into the Korean economy and
this was in a time when the 90s when
Korea was developing still it was good
country but it was still developing um
it was nowhere near it wasn't as
developed as Japan but similar wasn't as
industrial
um those girls all ended up getting
[__] over though because like they
they couldn't really rejoin Society so
they had these big demonstrations they
call them [__] walks where they were all
out there I remember protesting well
they had those kind of all over the
world yeah they wanted kind of like
social security for doing that service
but they probably for the for the Korean
government because they weren't yeah
because they weren't able to get married
as easily it does kind of [__] up your
life it [__] up your like I said not so
much nowadays but there's still a stigma
attached to it oh well even today yeah
like I said it lingers it's not as bad
yeah as it used to be but it's still bad
if you're a prostitute you're and you're
young you're going to have a problem
you're still going to yeah and well and
even Thomas said that too like even
doing what we do like on streamate or
like selling like porn videos and stuff
like we do he does not advise it for
people that are young no young if you're
a young woman and you want to get
married don't do it or if you want to
like get a good job or something like
that because could get in way people
might find some [__] but if you're old
like us and we don't give a [__] out or
anything yeah then it's fine yeah cuz
you know we're one we're already
married uh Purity is not at a premium
when you're our age right cuz everyone
kind of expects you expect to be your
been around sure you know that you've
been married a couple times that you you
know that you've been around like you
said right and I would say even in the
uh even in the let's say the lady ladies
of the
evening
um
that's really should be kind of more of
a career of a of a grown woman 40s hot
chick in her 40s you kind of get your
[__] together yeah and she's already had
her family or her chance to have a
family and that's not either not going
to happen or it did happen yeah or she's
not into it or whatever she's just not
really she lived that life already and
now she's going to do this you know what
I mean um to supplement an income or to
build a career on it
uh and she's wise enough to know who to
stay away from and what to do and you
know there's social there's applications
that you can use and she can vet clients
and what they all want if you understand
that industry and we know people that
are in that industry what they want is
they basically want a couple dozen
really solid regulars you know who are
older
guys with the disposable
income they're married business owners
basically half the time the wife knows
and uh they're basically crowdsourcing a
husband sure yeah well you know that
dude's safe he's not a serial killer you
know he's not going to [__] you over
yeah yeah and you don't have to worry
about him he come you see him [__]
once yeah you know what he likes it's
couple times a like a routine you might
see him once or twice a month then you
hang out with him and you know you get
broke off some and they all kind of add
up and um you know you're a hot chick in
your 40s so what nobody cares what
you're doing yeah but like I said like
you know I I wouldn't tell anybody else
what to do obviously but I kind of feel
like for younger women it might bite you
in the ass later on like I don't care
about it because I'm 51 but it's just
kind of like if you're in your 20s and
you're still kind of hoping to have you
have a whole life ahead of you yeah it
might be a little bit problematic what
you do and people might and it sucks but
people might have certain perceptions
about you that aren't true which like I
said it's better than it used to be but
there's still a stigma about
it still so you just got to know that
like going in yeah and you got you kind
of have to differentiate between
straight up prostitution and then
just the different kinds of adult
entertainment uh like you know a girl
who's a an amateur or professional
amateur
porn actress or if that's what you want
to call it or you want to say you know
[__] somebody who's creating content
online
through some of the platforms you know
only fans and stuff that's very
different from a studio porn star that's
a very different well yeah because
they're running them Studio porn stars
into the ground they do a lot of [__]
well honestly I think that's one of the
best things about the the way that stuff
is structured nowadays it's like if you
want to make your living that way you
can totally you could make a living
theoretically just selling videos of
yourself jerking off yeah C nobody else
is around you don't have to [__] any
random people that you don't know it's
just kind of like you can just do that
they got girls doing it yeah and girls
do do that now the the the data is going
to say that most of them are making
under $300 a week and that's
true so in other words full-time job
pays
more but what people don't realize is
that most of those girls are not using
that platform as a sole income yeah it's
just a side gig they have a job right
and then they're on the side to
supplement they put in a couple hours a
week doing an only like I said you can't
blame them send that $300 to a very
average person per week like I said
that's [__] car payment yeah that's
that's rent
okay so yeah people say well is it worth
compromising depends on who you are yeah
depends on who you are it also depends
exactly what you're
doing
um I wouldn't have any problems if I was
a young guy dating the only fans Creator
as long as she wasn't doing a whole
bunch of dudes on it you know I mean I'd
be a little bit it depends on exactly
what kind of deal it is you know but
most of them aren't doing that most of
them are doing a lot of solo stuff yeah
they just do [__] in their house yeah
now um Studio porn star
nah they they work them they they those
girls work a lot okay and they only get
paid for the for the production they
don't get any
residuals which is so they get paid just
on that one day and maybe they made a
thousand that day but then what they had
to do man a lot of that [__] pretty
[__] rough it is and then they start
to develop expensive taste and [__] now
and they're sugaring or escorting on the
side so usually if you're dealing with a
studio pornstar you're also dealing with
an escort so you got to ask yourself
well like I said they got to make money
some yeah well they're saying like well
I could do this what ends up happening
with them is that the the studio porn
stuff is more like the advertising for
the excort service right she gets uh
$1,000 on that one day to do this scene
with these dudes but she gets $1,700 for
a few hours from some fan who actually
looked better than the dude she had to
screw in the scene it might have been
some [__] like that you don't know
um or she might stay three days with
some dude who [__] dropped 10,000 on
her they that exists too and he was over
in Dubai somewhere she he flew her out
there and
everything but you got to ask yourself
this is a woman in her 20s why is she
doing this a lot of times either poverty
or drugs that's why she how they get or
maybe she just really doesn't want to
have a regular job which I get very few
from what I understand the only one that
[__] that I knew that that I know of
that got Angela White was an Australian
chick who wanted to be a porn star as
soon as she was 18 she she already had
called
him she was already calling [__] uh
Studios out in uh LA and she went down
there and immediately became full-time
porn star she she likes that but she's
I've seen interviews with her she she
actually wants to be in a relationship
but she wants to do porn at the same
time and
that that doesn't work she doesn't want
to have a relationship with anybody in
the industry she wants a regular
relationship with some [__] because I
kind of feel like if you're going to
have a relationship if you're in the
porn industry you're going to have a
relationship with someone else in the
porn industry yeah but what's funny is
that you find out that a lot of those
girls that are in the in that industry
don't like the guys in that industry
they don't want anything sure I get that
see guys is like real lowend because
they don't get paid much and um it's the
same guys over and over again it's like
a lot of those Studios like only have
[__] 15 dudes that they're using over
and over again so they're like a [__]
those dudes and those dudes are probably
sugaring and escorting themselves but
with dudes so you don't know well yeah
like I said everybody got to make money
somewhere you're right those guys don't
get paid much so they got to make money
somewhere yeah I don't begar anybody
trying to make some [__] money so
yeah but that's the thing it's like you
have to understand that there are you
know as shitty as it is there are
repercussions to doing the [__] like I
said I'm too old to care but well we
passed it we passed the we passed to the
age where it's would be like a real
socially DET detrimental to us and we're
already married yeah and like I said we
don't do anything that we don't want to
do when we don't do anything that we
don't want to do we just do [__] with
each other or or Solo solo [__] that
each of us knows about so it's just kind
of like no one's here and any other
female talent that ever wanted to get
involved was like my ex-girlfriends and
sh she knows that she's friends with and
this [__] would be kind of fake anyway
that's what I mean so it's you're just
making you're making a movie right so
we're not it matter it's not super
concerned but you
know that's how you had a dream the
other night about
[__] do I want to mention the the
place in Orlando did you tell me that
about this dream no I don't think I did
because I don't know even what you're
talking about I had a dream about
Secrets okay yeah yeah secret is a
swinger club I had a dream about that
yeah my ex and her husband got
to yeah for some reason like what was it
last night they keep inviting us to go
there I know I'm just like they've sent
us videos videos [__] they're
doing from the [__] like come on coming
down here look look what we're doing I'm
just like I don't know I don't know they
got cuties to go there they do
there there are married people married
people married people of all ages it's
like so sketchy but [__] it's like a
love hotel with a pool it is yeah and a
bar and you got to buy a membership to
get in there it's not technically not
open to the public I kind of laughed
because somebody on my friend's list I
don't remember who it was it was
somebody that I don't know personally
but they posted I guess they're from
here but they they posted a picture of
secrets and they said have you been
there but don't say what it is yeah like
cuz they're trying to be like all sneaky
about it and I was just kind of like
holy crap and like some people said oh
my God like some girl keeps trying like
at mannequins keeps trying to invite me
to that yeah I know who she's talking
about too I yeah I do too yeah but
um Stephie yeah
yeah yeah I get it yeah you know what
I'm talking about I don't know it's like
a
weirdly
the I don't know the pictures of it it
it looks
so
sketchy it looks so
sketchy one the rooms has got fake
stones on the inside [__] it's got
[__] it's a sers club on the ceiling
and pay it's a hotel waterfalls and [__]
in the room but you pay for a membership
yeah yes to get in yeah I don't think
you to pay for the rooms do you I don't
know how it works I I don't really know
you'd have to ask have to pay for the
rooms too but you pay for M it's like a
whole swingers thing yeah like everybody
that stays there like knows what the
deal is so it's like you kind of go in
the hot tub or the pool or whatever and
it's like oh everybody's going to like
yeah it's like it's kind of weird but I
had a dream that we went there I think
you have to be I guess because we keep
getting
messages I'm not sure if I'm not sure if
single guys are allowed to go in there
or not I would imagine they probably are
not because that would just cause
problems maybe there's no telling I had
to look at the rules it's married
couples and single females probably yeah
well they don't want and you could
probably a married couple can probably
bring a guest probably yeah I'd
imagine but yeah I had didn't dream
about going there isn't that weird I
think it was like two nights ago it's on
the mind
huh I think it was because well didn't
you show me that
video of that they made that they made
that they made there yeah yeah
I got like three of them that they made
there oh he I hav't seen them all you
kept yeah know one of them is out in the
parking lot oh you didn't show me that
one yeah you only showed me man you
there's all kind of [__] going on you
haven't told me abouton
Tony I've only seen one video that
you've told me yeah about Tony and some
other dude are just tearing up this
[__] chick that they got her in a car
and they're [__] oh I haven't seen
that one yeah and I think El's involved
you should be I think I heard El's voice
a couple times and maybe her hand
[__] get into the camera [__] grab
on her a little
bit Yeah Yeah Tony showed me all he he
sent me about four three or four videos
really I've only seen one yeah yeah so
there's all kind of stuff that's going
on that I don't know about oh I just
didn't I just didn't show you that one I
got them all the same time oh okay you
showed me one but yeah I saw
one Tony [__] no I'm just saying
right yeah you should be one of Tony
[__] somebody with a l lay in there
next to him yeah yeah that's like the
that wasn't a video though yeah it was
was it a video I thought that was just a
photograph no okay no I remember
you but yeah it's just funny that well I
think hot too I think I thought of it
because somebody posted on YouTube or on
Facebook about it yeah like but not
saying what it was it's like hey have
you ever been here but don't say what it
is you know what I mean I was like I
know what it is because we've like
[__] invited there but you
know I ain't worried about it I don't
care I don't care [__] that one chick
that wanted to do uh that joined our
Gothic Orlando that [__] and what her
post was does it does anybody make
content I'm looking for somebody to make
that might want to make content and
[__] then I said yeah said me and my
wife make content she oh yeah yeah turn
she goes there yeah all right just to
hang out okay yeah she doesn't say she
doesn't do anything there she just she
says it's just a safe club to go to okay
she might she might be a nudest I don't
know I don't know I've never been so I
don't know but you know she's making
content and uh hanging out there I
showed her to
you did you I don't remember yeah I
showed her to you I mean you might have
but I don't
remember short chick with a big boobs
that I forg her name that really doesn't
narrow
downtown really she knew who she knew
she knew who L Antony were oh okay well
I kind of feel like everybody knows
there Hugo says you guys were lucky to
find each other I
think probably to be honest we didn't
really think about it like that at the
time I
guess it just kind of natural laws of
physics and [__] because of where we
were hanging out what our personalities
were like it was going to happen
probably yeah I mean not so much luck
but it was
selective like I said I was at we were
at the [__] club where people like us
hang out yeah I think it was more that
yeah I think it was more of that than
anything that takes a lot of lot of the
chats out of it cuz we we knew that we
were into the same kind of [__] but like
I said I noticed
him even
before I mean I was still married at the
time cuz I used to go to that club with
my
ex-husband um I noticed him even before
I don't even want to say like even
before me and the husband were having
problems cuz maybe not I probably
wouldn't have noticed another dude if we
weren't having problems previously
because I'm not like that kind of person
but yeah it might have been the kind of
thing where it's like hey look at that
dude like man he's like a snappy dresser
and he can actually dance which you know
like I said a lot of dudes
can't which is disappointing but um but
yeah so I I kind of feel like it was
that I can't really remember it was a
long time ago I can't really remember
like how long it was prior to cuz look
me and my ex-husband like I said we were
married for 14 years we got married in
1995 and we divorced in 200
10 2009 [__] I can't
remember but I can't remember like how
long it was
like prior to that that we were like
having problems the weird thing about it
is
that from what I remember and it was a
while
back but for a while we had a house we
had bought a house in
Daytona Beach in Florida and for a while
we lived there together but separate
like I was going out with different like
he was sleeping in another room and I
was going out with different dudes and
he knew about it and it was like okay
you know what I mean no I said when me
and my ex-husband broke up okay yeah
um but while we were going through the
divorce or while we were going through
separation like we were sleeping in
separate rooms and like I was going to
the club by myself and like you know
going out with other dudes and stuff and
he knew about it he wasn't happy about
it but he was like okay with it yeah
like he wasn't upset about it cuz he's
like okay I get it so it was that kind
of situation until I had enough money to
like move out you know what I mean yeah
so it was that kind of thing cuz we did
live in the same house for a little
while and then I moved out cuz I moved
to Orlando like I got an
apartment
but uh Danny Rowling said Tom and Jenny
what t tattoos do you want to get next
honestly I for a long time I have been
wanting to get a back piece based on
mask of the Red Death the Edgar Allen
post
story but I just haven't been able to
afford it I want to like a whole bag
like I had the an idea of it and
everything like what it's going to look
like and I've even done like some AI
drawings of it and [__] like that like
some cool shit's coming out but but I
don't know I just can't afford it if I
got anything that if I got anything more
than man I I had to spend all kind of
money on it I just get a sleeve done all
the way
down probably just get a sleeve done and
probably I don't know what theme it
would be not really I didn't really
think about
it I mean I would like a hole back and
like maybe two sleeves like well I mean
I like
this but I would like this to be I kind
of want like a whole like Egyptian thing
like around this one cuz this is
old so I kind of I'm getting sleepy are
you getting sleepy yeah it's getting
late all right well I'm having a good
time but okay well if you want to talk
you can talk I'm just gonna no it's all
right all right Danel rolling said Tom
should get elephant ears tattooed on the
top inside part of his thighs oh
yeah well you want some mud flaps yeah
you some my flaps all
right all right so I guess we're all
getting tired it's
quarter p 11 in Florida at this point so
I guess we're going to wrap it up for
the
evening you going to wrap it up for the
evening yeah all
right what you doing all right I'm
answering a message somebody wanting
money from me what yeah all right yeah
somebody wants money for some [__] yeah
murder Hornet oh okay yeah he s me the
money okay all right so we're going to
wrap it up um Monday we'll be back with
a a movie review not sure what movie
it's going to be because it'll be one
that we watch over the weekend so it's
as much of a surprise to us as it will
be to
you so hopefully you guys can join us
for that thank you for dropping by this
evening thank you for your super chats
tonight always appreciated and we will
see you guys again on Monday night good
night